STATE SENATE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE AND INVITE AUTHORS TO
TESTIFY AND WE LIKE TO CALL ALL
MEMBERS TO THE COMMITTEE.
AND WE WILL REACH A CORPSMAN AND
BE ABLE TO VOTE ON THE BILLS SO --
IT THIS TIME -- WILL CONTINUE WE
LIKE TO KEEP -- THE ROOM QUIET
SO WE WANT YOU TO TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OUTSIDE.
AND TURN YOUR PHONES OFF AND ALL
THAT SO WE CAN -- CONDUCT
BUSINESS HERE -- AND WE'LL GET
WE'LL GET TO A QUORUM PRETTY
SOON BUT WE WANT TO ALLOW THE
OFFICES START SO -- THE FIRST
BILL WILL TAKE UP HIS ITEMS
[inaudible]
THREE AND MR DAILY ASSEMBLYMAN
DALY HAS A BILL AB -- FORTY
SEVEN THANK YOU TURN OVER TO HIM
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLYMAN WELCOME
TO THE SENATE.
PETITION COMMITTEE SIR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES -- TEXTING
WHILE DRIVING.
DISTRACTED DRIVING CAN BE AS
DEADLY AS IMPAIR DRIVING. FOR
DRIVING WHILE THE AFTER DRINKING.
THEREFORE I HAVE INTRODUCED THIS
BILL TO IMPROVE ROAD SAFETY.
IF THIS BILL BECOMES LAW
EVERYONE WHO DRIVES ROADS OF OUR
STATE WILL BE SAFER.
THIS BILL STRENGTHENS THE
PENALTY FOR DISTRACTED DRIVING
BY ADDING A POINT VIOLATION ON A
PERSON'S DRIVING RECORD. FOR THE
SECOND OR ANY SUBSEQUENT
CONVICTION.
RESEARCH SUGGESTS TO DRIVERS WHO
TEXT MESSAGE WHILE DRIVING ARE
EIGHT TIMES AS LIKELY TO BE IN
AN ACCIDENT.
AS DRIVERS WHO ARE NOT TEXTING.
UNFORTUNATELY OUR EXISTING
DISTRACTED DRIVING LAWS HAVE NOT
DONE ENOUGH TO DETER THIS
DANGEROUS PRACTICE.
DMV RECORDS SHOW THAT. THREE
YEARS AGO THERE WERE
[inaudible]
TWO HUNDRED NINE THOUSAND
OFFENSES. FOR TEXTING WHILE
DRIVING. TWO YEARS AGO THERE
WERE TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND OFFENSES SO THAT
REPRESENTED A 20% INCREASE THOSE
OF THE MOST RECENT DMV NUMBERS.
BUT THE OFFENSE IS GREW BY 20%
IN JUST ONE YEAR.
THE CURRENT PENALTIES A BASE
FINE OF TWENTY DOLLARS FOR FIRST
VIOLATION AND FIFTY DOLLARS FOR
SUBSEQUENT VIOLATIONS HAVE HAD
LITTLE IF ANY IMPACT.
AS THOSE -- THE NUMBERS SHOW.
BY ELEVATING IT DISTRACTED
DRIVING CITATION TO THE SAME
STATUS AS OTHER DANGEROUS
DRIVING VIOLATIONS SUCH AS
SPEEDING A RUNNING A RED LIGHT.
THIS MEASURE SHOULD HELP MAKE
THE ROADS SAFER.
THE COMMITTEE HAS SUGGESTED
AMENDMENT TO DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION UNTIL JANUARY
FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY ONE THIS IS
TO ACCOMMODATE OUR DMV AND OTHER
PROCEDURAL MATTERS I READILY
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENT
AND THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR IN YOUR COMMITTEE
FOR THOSE. FOR THAT AMENDMENT
WITH ME TODAY IS MIKE KNUDSEN ON
BEHALF OF THE AUTOMOBILE CLUB OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WHO ARE THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL
AND JONATHON FELDMAN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION?
OKAY THANK YOU WILL BEFORE WE
TEST MY LIPS -- WE REACH A
QUORUM SO WILL CALL THE ROLL AND
ESTABLISH -- OUR COMMITTEE SO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CENTER
ABOUT YOUR BELL PRESENT BATES.
BATES PRESENT DALI.
DALI PRESENT DODD.
GALGIANI HERE GALGIANI PRESENT
MCGUIRE MORALE.
I'LL PRESENT ROTH RUBIO.
RUBIO PRESENT SKINNER STONE.
STONE PRESENT UMBERG CASKEY.
OKAY WE GOT A CORE NOW --
BUSINESS AND YOU HAVE THE FLOOR
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
CONCERN HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
OWNER OF THE CLUB OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA -- WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL WE THINK IT
WILL WILL HAVE A DRAMATIC IMPACT
IN HELPING TO CHANGE THE CULTURE
RELATED TO TEXTING AND DRIVING
THAT'S ITS PURPOSE -- THIS IS AN
ALLY ARE ESSENTIALLY A LOOPHOLE
AND HOW WE TREAT OTHER --
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR DANGEROUS
DRIVING ACTIVITIES.
WE THINK IT WILL BE VERY HELPFUL
IN AND KIND OF ADDRESSING THAT
CHANGING THE CULTURE AND WE
WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
IN OTHER OTHERS SPEAKERS PLEASE.
GEN MEMBERS JONATHON FELDMAN THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION DISTRACTED DRIVING
IS A MAJOR PUBLIC SAFETY THREAT --
AND WE NEED TO TREAT IT AS SUCH
RIGHT NOW THE PENALTIES DON'T
EVEN MEASURE IT WAS SOME OF THE
MUCH.
LOWER TRAFFIC VIOLATIONS IN THIS
BRING SOME PARITY IN AND WITH
THE EXPRESSES THAT THIS IS A
MAJOR PUBLIC SAFETY CONCERN.
THAT NEEDS TO BE TREATED AS SUCH
WE ASCRIBE [inaudible]
THANK.
MR MEMBERS RYAN SHERMAN WITH THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
DISTRACTED DRIVING CONTINUES TO
BE AN ALL TOO FREQUENT CAUSE A
SERIOUS AND DEADLY INSTANCES ON
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHWAYS.
HOWEVER THE EXISTING PENALTY FOR
DISTRACTED DRIVING A FINE
SENSUALLY IS THE EQUIVALENT TO A
PARKING TICKET AND WE ARE DRIVE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
HERE AND READ REVIEWS AND
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HIGHWAY PATROLMAN AND ALSO
IMPACT TEEN DRIVERS.
I THINK THE CHP PROBABLY SEES
MORE OF THIS AND ANYBODY ELSE --
PROBABLY MOST OF CITATIONS THAT
WERE REFERENCED BY THE AUTHOR --
WERE ISSUED BY THE SIEGE P. AND
THEY SEE THE CARNAGE THEY SEE
THE DEATH AND THIS BILL WILL
HELP PEOPLE TAKE A SECOND.
LOOK AT WHAT THEY'RE DOING AND
MAYBE NOT.
TEXT WHILE THEY'RE DRIVING.
WE ARE SUPPORTING IT.
IF YOU CHAIRMAN JAMES AMMAR
BEHALF THE ABATED CALIFORNIA
MOTORCYCLE RIGHTS ORGANIZATION --
TO STIR TWO DAYS AGO SEVEN
BETTER MOTORCYCLES WERE KILLED
IN VERMONT AND NEW HAMPSHIRE.
OF BY A PERSON WE'RE NOT SURE IF
HE WAS IN A DISTRACTED DRIVER
BUT IT'S A VERY SERIOUS PROBLEM
WE HAVE A LOT OF PROTECTION
AROUND OUR VEHICLES SO WE
SUPPORT THE BILL THANKS.
THANK YOU -- OTHERS BECAUSE MAY --
ADDRESSES AND TELLS YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION THANK
YOU.
CAN STONE STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF ALL STATE INSURANCE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MANY LAY ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN
PROPERTY CASUALTY INSURERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS THE
AMALGAMATED TRANSIT UNION AND
SUPPORT.
THANK OTHERS SPEAKERS IN FAVOR
PLEASE [inaudible]
OKAY -- WE HAVE THE SPEAKERS
OPPOSING THIS BILL COME FOR
PLEASE.
A BY POST.
OKAY IF NOT WE HAVE -- QUESTIONS.
THERE'S A MOTION BEFORE HE BILL
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
I SEE NONE -- THIS SUMMER WHEN
YOU MAY -- CLOSURE MAKE A
CLOSING STATEMENT PLEASE THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE THE EXPRESSIONS
OF SUPPORT FROM SO MANY.
GROUPS AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEES -- ANALYSIS OF THE
BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
THIS IS A SIMILAR BILL FORTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAILY
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
CENTER ABOUT I FELL AYE BATES
AYE BATES AYE DALI.
DALI AYE DODD.
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE
MORALE.
HI MORRELL HI ROSS RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER STONE.
STONE I AM BURKE CASKEY -- SEVEN
VOTES IN FAVOR ZERO AGAINST WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMAN
WILL CALL.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN NINE YOU AGAIN IS
[inaudible]
RAY [inaudible] FOR SHE HAS
TO AND ASSEMBLY WOMAN HAS AB.
ONE SEVENTY NINE WHICH IS ITEM.
FOR SHE ALSO HAS ITEM FOURTEEN
A. B..
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN SO YOU
WOULD YOU LIKE TO START WITH IN
THOSE IN ORDER.
OKAY YOU HAVE THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY PRESENT TO YOU AB ONE
SEVENTY NINE A BILL THAT MAKES
CHANGES TO THE FRANCHISE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN CALIFORNIA
NEW CAR DEALERS AND AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURERS.
NEW CAR DEALERS OPERATING AS
LOCAL INDEPENDENTLY OWNED OR
FRANCHISED DEALERSHIPS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
EMPLOY OVER ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA AND IN SOME
COMMUNITIES ARE THE MAJOR SOURCE
OF ECONOMIC ACTIVITY.
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT THE
BALANCE OF POWER BETWEEN LARGE
MULTINATIONAL AUTO MAKERS AND
CALIFORNIA'S NEW CAR DEALERS IS
A FAIR AND COMPETITIVE PLAYING
FIELD.
THIS BILL MAKES THE FOLLOWING
KEY CHANGES TO CALIFORNIA MOTOR
VEHICLE FRANCHISE LONG.
PROVIDES A SYSTEM FOR NEW CAR
DEALERS TO REQUEST FOR
MANUFACTURERS RETAIL
REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR WORK
PERFORMED UNDER WARRANTY WHICH
ALIGNS CALIFORNIA WITH FORTY
OTHER STATES.
CLARIFIES THE DEALERS CAN BRING
PROTESTS TO THE MOTOR VEHICLE TO
THE NEW MOTOR VEHICLE BOARD
REGARDING UNREASONABLE
PERFORMANCE STANDARDS.
YEAH BUT THE MANUFACTURE FROM
TAKING ADVERSE ACTION AGAINST A
DEALER RELATED TO EXPORT.
POLICIES PROHIBITS UNREASONABLE
FACILITY UPGRADES AND ALLOWS A
DEALER TO USE A CALIFORNIA
VENDOR FOR SIMILAR LIKE MIND
LIKE KIND MATERIALS CONSTRUCTION
AND INSTALLATION.
AND ALLOWS DEALER ALLOWS DEALERS
WITH MANUFACTURE APPROVAL TO
SEEK THEIR OWN VENDORS FOR
DIGITAL SERVICES LIKE WEBSITES
AND DEALER MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS.
THIS BILL IS A PRODUCT OF WELL
OVER TWENTY HOURS OF
NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN THE SPONSOR
AND AUTOMAKERS.
HERE WITH ME TODAY TODAY TO
TESTIFY.
AND ANSWER QUESTIONS IS CLIFF
CLIFF ACOSTA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NEW CAR DEALERSHIPS.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CLIP COSTA
MAY HAVE THE CALIFORNIA NEW CAR
DEALERS ASSOCIATION FIRST ONE I
THINK THE AUTHOR.
OF FOR ALL HER EFFORTS AND
MOVING FOR THIS BILL --
FRANCHISE LAWS ARE IMPORTANT NOT
JUST TO DEALERS BUT ALSO TO
CONSUMERS BY THE BEEN AROUND
SINCE -- NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE
EVERY FEW YEARS WE COME AND WE
ASK FOR SOME HELP TO BALANCE THE
INEQUITIES BETWEEN INTERNATIONAL
CONGLOMERATES THE AUTO MAKERS.
AND ARE LOCALLY OWNED
INDEPENDENTLY OWNED NEW CAR
DEALERS MANY OF WHOM STILL
OPERATE AS FAMILY BUSINESSES
MANY OF WHOM YOU ALREADY KNOW IN
YOUR DISTRICTS -- THIS BILL
LOOKS FAMILIAR TO YOU.
MOST OF YOU AT LEAST -- THIS
BILL WAS VETOED LAST YEAR -- ON
THE VERY NIGHT LAST NIGHT.
NEEDLESS TO SAY -- WE HAVE SPENT
MANY HOURS THIS YEAR GOING BACK
AND FURTHER REFINING THE BILL
THAT MANY OF YOU ALREADY VOTED
FOR LAST YEAR -- WE HAVE REACHED
WHAT I LIKE TO CALL AN
UNDERSTANDING -- WITH OUR AUTO
MAKER FRIENDS -- THE WILL BE
APPEARING AND WILL TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION STILL -- BUT WE
BELIEVE WE'VE ADDRESSED THE
CONCERNS LAID OUT BY GOVERNOR
BROWN TO VETO HE SAID THE
WARRANTY REIMBURSEMENT FORMULA
WAS TOO COMPLICATED THE SIMPLE
FIGHT THAT -- AND SO I AM AS THE
AUTHOR SAID AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS IF YOU'D LIKE
TO ASK SPECIFIC QUESTIONS BUT ON
BEHALF OF MY MEMBERS I'D
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU VERY OTHERS SPEAKERS
IN FAVOR PLEASE MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE JAMES AMMAR
MAP THE CALIFORNIA MOTORCYCLE
DEALERS ASSOCIATION --
MOTORCYCLES ARE MOTOR VEHICLES
SO WE'RE INCLUDED UNDER THE NAME
OF NEW MOTOR VEHICLE BOARD -- IT
GIVES US THE ABILITY IF THE
MANUFACTURER WILL NOT REPAIR
MOTORCYCLE.
BECAUSE OF IT SO LIMóN WE CAN
TAKE THAT TO THE NEW MOTOR
VEHICLE BOARD WITH THE CONSUMER
AND ET SOME SATISFACTION FOR
THAT CONSUMER.
AND 98% A TIME WHEN SAID ACTIONS
FILED THE WE GET A SETTLEMENT
AND THE CONSUMERS HAPPY SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN OR IN
SUPPORT.
HEY -- TWELVE OTHERS SPEAKERS
THAT SUPPORT THIS BILL COME
FORWARD [inaudible]
OKAY -- GOING TO HEAR FROM
SPEAKERS OPPOSING THE BILL.
YES FOR TOMORROW.
HAVE A SEAT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN IS THE COMMITTEE
JOHN MOFFITT ON BEHALF OF THE
ALLIANCE OF AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURERS.
WHEN THE THINK THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS FOR FOR WORKING -- AS
AS WAS NOTED MANY MANY HOURS ON
ON REACHING WHICH YOU SEE IN THE
BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY --
ALTHOUGH WE ARE OPPOSED WE DO
BELIEVE THIS IS A BETTER PRODUCT
THAN WHAT WAS SENT TO THE
GOVERNOR LAST YEAR.
AND WE WANT TO THINK THE AUTHOR
AND SPONSORS FOR WORKING WITH US
EARLY THIS YEAR TO GET THIS --
GET THE BILL HAMMERED OUT IN THE
FORM YOU SEE BEFORE YOU.
OTHER PEOPLE OPPOSE PLEASE.
QUESTIONS WERE COMMITTEE --
THERE'S A MOTION. FOR THE BILL.
AND WILL ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
WILL CALL ASSEMBLY WOMAN JOY TO
MAKE A CLOSING STATEMENT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL OKAY THANK YOU.
AND WILL CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
SEVENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RIGHT YES THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFER TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
CENTER ABOUT BY WELL I BATES.
BATES AYE DALI.
DALI AYE DODD GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE MORALE
[inaudible]
ROSS [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
STONE STONE I AM BURKE WHAT
CASTING HI KATHY I REALLY TO
BROWN I YOU HAVE A VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE FROM FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS OF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THE
AUTHOR SHE HAS.
YOU HAVE ANOTHER BILL.
OKAY WILL CALL -- UP THE ITEM.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN FOR OMNI TRANS TRANSISTORS.
YOU HAVE THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN IS A-SIMPLE BILL WHICH PROPOSES TO
DISSOLVE THE EXISTING OMNITRANS
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY AND
REFORM IT INTO OMNITRANS SPECIAL
TRANSIT DISTRICT.
OMNITRANS IS THE PUBLIC TRANSIT
AGENCY THAT WAS FORMED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX CURRENTLY
IT OFFERS PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
THROUGHOUT THE SAN BERNADINO
VALLEY SERVING CITIES INCLUDING
COLTON FONTANA GRANT TEARS.
RIALTO AND SANDRA DINO ALL OF
WHICH ARE IN MY DISTRICT.
CURRENTLY ON THE TRANS IS
LOOKING TO EXPAND ITS SERVICES
INCLUDING TO THE REDLANDS
PASSENGER RAIL PROJECT.
AND THAT WILL BE IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE THE REDLANDS
PASSENGER RAIL PROJECT IS AN
ADVANCED REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
PROJECT DESIGNED TO CONNECT
RESIDENTS BUSINESSES AND
VISITORS TO A VARIETY OF
DESTINATION.
DESTINATIONS FOR LEISURE
EDUCATION AND HEALTHCARE AND
OTHERS.
IN ADDITION IT WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE THE FIRST RAIL
PROJECT IN NORTH AMERICA TO TEST
A BATTERY POWERED TRAIN
FURTHERING OUR CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION GOALS.
SIMPLY AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
WILL CREATE OMNITRANS SPECIAL
DISTRICT IN ORDER TO BE BETTER
ABLE TO PROVIDE A NEW INNOVATIVE
AND A VITAL TRANSPORTATION
SERVICE TO THE INLAND EMPIRE.
I HAVE AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH A HOST OF STAKEHOLDERS TO
ENSURE THIS TRANSITION IS ONE
THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH OTHER
SPECIAL.
DISTRICT DISTRICT TRANSFERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE HERE WITH
ME TO TESTIFY SY RECEIVERS ON
BEHALF OF ON THE TRANCE.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS OF THE
AND TAKING ON A TRAIN SERVICE
IT'S A LONGER TERM COMMITMENT
AND MORE FINANCIAL.
INVESTMENT IN SO THIS BILL WILL
GIVE THEM A MORE STABLE LONG
TERM STRUCTURE THAN THE JPA
FORMAT WILL THAT'S WITH THE
PURPOSE BEHIND THE BILL.
I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
WOULD LIKE TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
EVERY SUPPORTERS FOR THE BILL
COME FOR PLEASE -- XENON
OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FOR A THE AUTHOR.
OF QUESTION.
WORK OUT THIS.
BY MAKING THIS A SPECIAL
DISTRICT THIS IS CHANGE THE
ELIGIBILITY FOR FUNDING LIKE CAP
AND TRADE OR WERE YOU GUYS
ALREADY.
ELIGIBLE WITH GPA TO NOW.
THERE ARE THERE.
THINK OF THEM ALMOST AS A SUBSET
OF THE SANDY ASSEMBLY DOWN
TRANSIT AUTHORITY.
TAMMY COUNTY TRANSIT AUTHORITY
AS PC TA SAY RELIEF TO THE
FUNDING THROUGH THERE YES TELL
DAD ANSWER QUESTIONS.
AND I I KNOW I GOT AN ANSWER
FROM HERE -- OFFICE AND BULLET
NUMBER FIVE TO TALKS ABOUT
COMPETITIVE BIDDING -- FOR
PROJECTS OVER TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IS THAT FROM NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX ALSO WERE IT JUST
SEEMS LIKE A PUNY AMOUNT OF WORK
GIVEN. TWENTY NINETEEN IT IS BUT
I'LL LET MISTER DEAVER'S.
RESPOND THANK YOU THE AS WE DID
BORROW LANGUAGE AND TALKING WITH
THE CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION TO
JUST REACH AGREEMENT WITH THEM
QUICKLY WE DID AGREE TO EXISTING
STATUTORY LANGUAGE THAT WAS IN
FACT FROM THE SEVENTIES.
WE DIDN'T FEEL AS NECESSARY TO
UPDATE IT BECAUSE IN FACT
THEY'RE GOING TO SIGN AN
AGREEMENT WHICH BASICALLY ALLOWS
THEM TO OPERATE IN THE HIGHER
STANDARDS THAT THEY AGREE TO
CERTAIN TRANSPARENCY MEASURES.
THANKS.
I'M OF THE BILL.
THERE'S A MOTION -- I WANT
QUESTION -- TELL ME ABOUT THE
POWER.
TRAIN ON THE TRAIN.
HOW THAT WORKS?
IS THIS CLEAN RIGHT IT'S A I
LIKE TO YOUR YEAH I KNOW IT'S
VERY EXCITING AND BY ME YEAH I
CAN CAN'T DUMP GONNA WORK IT'S A
PROOF OF CONCEPT DESIGN THE
OTHER GOING TO SWAP OUT A DIESEL
ELECTRIC ENGINE FOR A LITHIUM
ION BATTERY PACK.
SO THIS WILL RUN ON BATTERY
POWER NO OVERHEAD LINES NO
POWERED RAILS -- IF THIS WORKS
THIS COULD BE TRANSFORMATIVE.
WITH THE SYSTEM OKAY WE WANT TO
FOLLOW THE PROGRESS OF THAT FOR
SURE.
THEY'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
GETTING A FOURTH TRYING OR THIRD
TRYING.
A LETTER AT THE FOURTH CAR YES
FOR THE FOURTH CURRENT.
WE HAVE A MOTION -- WILL CALL
THE ROLL.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRANCE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE.
SENATOR ABOUT.
WELL I BATES BATES AYE DOLLY.
DODD GALGIANI DOT I GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE.
MORALE [inaudible]
ROTH.
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER
STONE.
STONE I AMBER WITHOUT SKI.
BECAUSE HE AYE [inaudible]
YEAH.
OKAY WE DON'T HAVE ANY OFFERS
BUT WE HAVE A CONSENT TO OUR
MOTION TO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR CONSENT
CALENDAR.
CONSENT COUNTY ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIMPLY.
ONE WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT COUNTER AND FIRST
CONSENT CALENDAR.
I'M A REAL PLEASE ON THE FIRST
CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH CONSISTS
OF FILE ITEMS 257-913-1617
EIGHTEEN AND NINETEEN CENTER
ABOUT ART BELL AYE BATES AYE
BATES AYE DOLLY.
DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MORALE.
ROTH RUBIO HI RUBIO AYE SKINNER
STONE [inaudible]
ROSS RUBIO.
SO I SKINNER [inaudible]
STONE.
STONE I AM BURKE.
CASKEY.
WE GOT THE AYE. SEVEN THAT IS A
SEVEN ZERO VOTE AND YES I DO
WANT TO GET RID MEMBERS
[inaudible] ONE WE'RE GONNA
CALL THE ROLL AGAIN ON ITEM ONE
ON THE THE AB.
FORTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DALY. FOR THE MEMBERS OF JUST
JOINED US.
WE'RE VOTING NOW ON AB.
FORTY SEVEN CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAILY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
SENATOR DODD.
DODD I AM A CHOIR MCGUIRE AYE
ROSS.
RUBIO.
RUBIO I AM BURKE.
CASKEY.
NOW IT HAS TEN ZERO AND A FEW
MORE MEMBERS COMING ONLY THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
NEXT.
ONE OKAY THE NEXT ONE WE VOTED
ON IS AB.
ONE SEVENTY NINE AND WILL CALL
THE ROLL ON THAT PLEASE.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
SEVENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RIGHT YES THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFER TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
SENATOR DOT DOT.
DODD I'M AROUND [inaudible]
ROSS [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
CONSIDERING.
I DON'T BELIEVE I VOTED ON
EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY NINE I WAS
OUT OF THE ROOM.
THE ONE SEVEN FIVE THIS IS
SIMPLY WHAT THE BILL ONE SEVENTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RANTS THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
DO. TO THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
SENATE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
[inaudible]
YEAH
.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA WAIT FOR SOME
AUTHORS
[inaudible]
WHAT [inaudible]
THE
OTHER.
WE HAVE AN OFFER.
OKAY -- WE'LL GET STARTED WILL
GO -- TO ITEM.
TEN ASSEMBLYMAN O'DONNELL IS
HERE A. B..
FOURTEEN OH SIX AND WE'LL HEAR
THIS BILL AND SEVEN WHEN YOU
HAVE THE FOR THANK YOU FOR
WRITING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE
TO START BY.
STATING I AM ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS -- THEY'RE
OFFERED BY THE COMMITTEE SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB
FORTINO SIX WHICH REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION. TO
ALLOCATE 10% OF FUNDS IN THE
ALTERNATIVE AND RENEWABLE FUEL
VEHICLE AND TECHNOLOGY PROGRAM.
TO ALTERNATE ALTERNATIVE FUEL.
IN ADVANCED TECHNOLOGY VEHICLES.
THE ALTERNATIVE FUEL PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED IN THE TWO THOUSANDS
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN TO DEVELOP
AND DEPLOY INNOVATIVE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT TRANSFORM
CALIFORNIA'S FUEL.
AND VEHICLE TYPES.
OVER THE LAST DECADE THE PROGRAM
HAS SUCCESSFULLY HELPED ATTAIN
STATE CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS BY
INVESTING IN A BROAD PORTFOLIO
OF TRANSPORTATION AND FUEL
PROJECTS THAT REDUCE GHG
EMISSIONS.
DESPITE THE SUCCESS.
THERE BEEN RECENT EFFORTS TO
UNDERMINE THE INTEGRITY OF THE
PROGRAM B ALLOCATING ALL
PROGRAM FRONTS. TO ONE SINGLE
PREFERRED TECHNOLOGY.
WELL SOME TECHNOLOGIES REDUCE
EMISSIONS MORE THAN OTHERS.
NO ONE TECHNOLOGY IS BEST FOR
ALL POTENTIAL USES AT THIS TIME.
FOR EXAMPLE MANY HAVE YOU ROOM
DUTY VEHICLES DO NOT HAVE
[inaudible]
VIABLE -- VIABLE -- ME.
A VIABLE ZERO EMISSION
REQUIREMENTS FOR THEIR FLEETS
BUT DO HAVE NEAR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE OPTIONS AVAILABLE.
THIS IS IMPORTANT TO MY OWN
DISTRICT I COME FROM LONG BEACH
I REPRESENT -- BOTH PORTS WE
HAVE A LOT OF HEAVY VEHICLE USED --
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES TRAVELING IN
AND OUT OF THE BOARDS AND SO
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR ME
THIS IS PERSONAL FOR ME --
BECAUSE WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS
REALLY GET AWAY FROM THESE ARE
HEAVY POLLUTING VEHICLES ON THE
EVER HERE TODAY IS TO DO THAT.
SO WITH ME HERE TODAY IS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS THOMAS
LAWSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL GAS VEHICLE
COALITION MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU A GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN BELLA COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME'S TOM SLAWSON ON THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
AFTER GAS WE WILL COALITION.
WE ARE THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL.
I WOULD FIRST LIKE TO THANK THE
CHAIRMAN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
DISCUSSES BILL AND FOR TO BE
HEARD AND I DEFINITELY WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF
ALL THE WORK THEY'VE DONE ON
THIS BILL TO GET US TO THIS
POINT.
AB FORTINO SIX SEEKS TO GET
CLEANER TRUCKS ON THE ROAD RIGHT
NOW TO GIVE CALIFORNIA'S ALL
OVERSEE CLEANER AIR TODAY.
PROVIDING IMMEDIATE AIR QUALITY
PRODUCTION SHOULD BE ONE OF OUR
HIGHEST PRIORITIES THE 10%
ALLOCATION THIS BILL IS
EQUIVALENT TO THE STORE GO
ALLOCATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN --
ALLOCATED TO THIS PARTICULAR
CATEGORY.
IT DOESN'T SEEK TO CREATE A NEW
PROGRAM OR TAKE MAJORITY OF THE
MONEY -- THE CALIFORNIA TO GUESS
VEHICLES FOR MYSELF I SIT ON THE
BUYERS ARE COMMITTEE AND WE'VE
SPENT QUITE A BIT OF TIME SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN TRYING TO
GET SOME MOVEMENT ON THE WAIT
LIST THAT HAS GONE FROM ONE
MILLION DOLLARS TO SIX MILLION
DOLLARS FOR FOLKS THAT -- HAVE
ACCESS PROGRAM AND WHAT I MEAN
BY FOLKS I'M TALKING ALL FLEETS
ALL OVER THE STATE THAT I WANTED
TO PURCHASE NEW TRUCKS.
HEAVY DUTY TRUCK EMISSIONS MAKE
UP MAJORITY OF OUR MISSIONS --
ISSUES.
SO AS THESE FLEETS ARE UNDER
GREATER PRESSURE TO GET CLEANER
NOW NOT NECESSARILY LATER ON IN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FORTY BUT
THEY'RE UNDER PRESSURE RIGHT NOW.
THEY ARE ACCESS IN OUR CENTER
PROGRAMS TO GET HELP FOR DOING
JUST THAT.
SO FOR FLEET WANTS TO PURCHASE
THE CLEAN HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE
TODAY.
WITH INSTEAD OF DOLLARS THAT ARE
DESIGNED FOR THAT PURPOSE WE
BELIEVE THAT THEY SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO DO THAT.
NATURAL GAS VEHICLES WHICH ARE
CERTIFIED TO THE LOW IS OPTIONAL
MISSION STANDARD AND POWERED BY
RENEWABLE FUEL.
ARE THE CLEANEST AVAILABLE
TECHNOLOGY TODAY AND HAVE A TWO
TRUCKS SECTOR.
FLEAS FROM CALIFORNIA HAVE SHOWN
THAT THEY WANT THESE VEHICLES.
AND WE CAN REDUCE EMISSIONS
TODAY AND AB FORTINO SIX IS THAT
ORANGE JUICE THAT.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
AND WE APPRECIATE NIVEAU.
SPEAKERS IN FAVOR PLEASE. FOR A
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR BELT
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
RYAN CANYON BEHALF OF CLEAN
ENERGY.
THE NATION'S LARGEST PROVIDER OF
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS
TRANSPORTATION FUEL IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- BRANDING OR
SEE ON BEHALF OF C. R.
NONVIOLENT A SERVICES AND
SUPPORT [inaudible]
OKAY -- WE HAVE OPPONENTS
COMPORT PLEASE.
HAVE A SEAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS --
I'M JULIE MALINOWSKI FALL ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA LECTER
TRANSPORTATION COALITION CAL ET
SEE IS A TRADE ASSOCIATION THE
STATE -- UTILITIES -- ELECTRIC
CAR PROVIDERS INFRASTRUCTURE
PROVIDERS AND TRUCK AND BUS
MANUFACTURERS -- KELLY T. C. IS
REGRETFULLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
IT IS NOT BECAUSE WE ARE OPPOSED
TO NATURAL GAS VEHICLES IN FACT
WE ACTUALLY SUPPORT THE
DIVERSITY THAT THE AIR F. E. B.
T. PROGRAM PROVIDES -- OUR OUR
OPPOSITION IS REALLY BASED ON
THE FACT THAT THERE IS ALREADY A
VERY ROBUST PUBLIC PROCESS --
THAT GOES ON TO DEVELOP THE
SPENDING PLAN FOR THIS PROGRAM
ANNUALLY -- CAL E. T. C. ALONG
WITH THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL
BENEFIT FROM THE ADDED THE ADDED
BENEFIT OF PARTICIPATING ON THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE SO AFTER
THERE HAVE BEEN LOTS OF
STAKEHOLDER WORKSHOPS IN
COMMENTS FILED A REPLY COMMENTS
FILED.
THE STAFF DEVELOP THE DRAFT
SPENDING PLAN IN THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE THEN GETS THE TO TO
ADVISE ON THAT SPENDING PLAN AND
THEN THE STAFF GOES BACK TO THE
DRAWING BOARD AND BASED ON THE
SPENDING PLAN THAT DEVICE YOU
PORTS COMMENTS.
THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT ACTUALLY
IS PROVIDING A LOT OF DIVERSITY --
IN ITS SPENDING -- AND SO IF
THERE'S A PROBLEM WITH THE
PROCESS WE THINK THIS BILL
SHOULD PROBABLY THAN TRY TO FIX
THAT PROCESS NOT TO A SET ASIDE --
FOR THE SPENDING WE WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT WE SUPPORT THE AUTHOR
AND WE SUPPORT THE SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL IN THEIR EFFORTS TO
AVOID THE USE OF FOSSIL FUELS
AND PROVIDE FUEL DIVERSITY WE
JUST DON'T THINK THIS BILL IS
THE WAY TO DO IT.
THANKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE OTHER
SPEAKERS PLEASE.
MY NAME IS KATHERINE GARCIA AND
I'M A POLICY ADVOCATE FOR SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA IS OPPOSED TO AB
FORTINO SIX WHICH WOULD
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATE FUNDS
TO ALTERNATIVE FUEL WHICH CAN
INCLUDE POLLUTING BIO FUELS.
THIS LEGISLATION WOULD UNDERMINE
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS TOWARDS A
ZERO EMISSION TRANSPORTATION
FUTURE.
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY TO THEM
WHEN YOU A FUEL PROGRAM.
WHICH STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN WAS PASSED TO HELP
CALIFORNIA REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IN THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR THROUGH A COMPETITIVE
PROCESS.
BY DESIGNATING THIS YEAR MARK
CALIFORNIA WILL LIMIT THE
FUNDING AWARDED TO INNOVATIVE
TECHNOLOGIES.
BIO FUELS GENERALLY ARE NOT
EMISSIONS FREE AND THEIR USE IN
COMBUSTION ENGINES CONTRIBUTE.
TO CLIMATE AND LOCALIZED AIR
POLLUTION.
A COMMITMENT TO BIO FUELS AND
ALTERNATIVE FUEL VEHICLES WOULD
HINDER CALIFORNIA.
EFFORTS TO ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE
AND CLEAN AIR GOALS.
THE STATE SHOULD NOT INVEST IN
STOP GAP MEASURES TO THE
DETRIMENT OF OUR COMMUNITIES
PLEASE VOTE NO ON FORTINO SIX
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OF OTHERS SPEAKERS
OPPOSING PLEASE.
I DON'T SEE ANY AND IT'S A GREAT
PERHAPS YOU CAN RESPOND TO SOME
OF THE CONCERNS.
MISTER CHAIR THING OUT AND WE
DID CAN YOU MAYBE -- EXPLAINED
THE AMENDMENT WE AGREE.
TO THE COMPROMISE YOU AGREE TO
THE AMOUNT YES.
AND THE I'D LISTEN THIS EFFORT
IS ABOUT CLEANER NOW.
MIGHT WE HAVE TECHNOLOGIES
AVAILABLE THAT ARE ZERO MISSION
IN TWENTY YEARS YES.
AND CERTAINLY I WELCOME THAT I
NEED THAT IN MY DISTRICT BUT WE
NEED CLEAN AIR TODAY WE DON'T
NEED CLEAN AIR TWENTY YEARS WE
NEED CLEANER TODAY AND THE THE
EFFORT OF THIS BILL.
IS TO GET US CLEAN AIR CLEANER
AIR SOONER -- THEN THEN THEN
WAITING FOR TWENTY YEARS FOR
SOME POTENTIAL TECHNOLOGY TO
POSSIBLY.
BE DEVELOPED AND ALL WE'RE
ASKING IS AGAIN IS FOR THAT 410%.
TO BE ALLOCATED TO TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL USES.
OKAY THE AMENDMENT TO BE CLEAR.
SUNSETS THIS PROVISION YES ON
JANUARY FIRST -- TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR SO [inaudible]
ESSENTIALLY -- WE'RE LEARNING --
A WINDOW.
YEAH BUT MY UNDERSTANDING IS THE
ENTIRE STATUTE.
ON THIS WILL SUNSET THE SAME
TIME SO THEY'LL BE A REALLY.
VIEW OF THAT STATUTE AS A WHOLE
AT THAT TIME IN AND THE SIDE OF
THE WHAT THEY WANT TO DO NEXT IN
TERMS OF WHAT THE TECHNOLOGY
EXISTS AT THAT TIME.
RIGHT THANK YOU THAT IS CORRECT
MISTER THINK THAT'S KIND OF THE
INTENTION OF THE SUNSET SO
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS -- AND IF
I MAY MISTER CHAIR -- WHERE I?
THE DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT
HAS TO HAS THE TWO PORTS
CERTAINLY WERE UNDER CARB RULES.
PRESSURE FROM THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES RESOURCE SUPPORT
WINNER PRESSURE FROM THE LOCAL
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
BUT EVEN ON OUR OWN -- WE'VE
TAKEN A VERY LOCAL APPROACH TO
THIS FOR THE CLEAN AIR ACTION
PLAN THREE POINT NO AND THE
EFFORT OF THIS BILLS TO HELP US
MEET THOSE GOALS AND AND IN A IN
A RAPID FASHION.
THE SOONER DODD DID YOU HAVE A
QUESTION [inaudible]
CLOSER DOLLY.
SENATOR DOLLY AS A PUSH I JUST
WANT TO SAY I APOLOGY THIS IS
AWESOME -- AS SOMEBODY WHO IS IN
THE TRANSPORTATION BUSINESS AND
TRYING TO MEET THE STANDARDS AND
THIS IS THE THIS IS A WE'RE
GOING TO IT'S GONNA TAKE US
YEARS TO GET TO ZERO EMISSIONS.
IN A WAY THAT ALLOWS -- HE WILL
PROVIDE THE SERVICES FOR US OUT
OF THE PORTS AND AND IT JUST IN
TRANSPORTATION GENERAL -- THIS
IS A COMMON SENSE APPROACH IT
ACTUALLY CAN CONVERT A LOT
EASIER -- TO THE VEHICLES TO
NATURAL GAS OR THOSE TYPES OF
DIFFERENT TYPES OF BIO FUELS.
VERSUS GOING -- TWO ZERO
EMISSION SO -- HOLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU FOR BRING IT FORWARD
AND THERE'S A GREAT COMMONSENSE
APPROACH APPRECIATED.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
DO YOU HAVE ANY CLOSING
STATEMENTS AT THIS TIME I'D ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE MISTER A WE HAVE
A MOTION ON THIS PLEASE.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION -- WE CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE ASSEMBLY BILL
FORTINO SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
O'DONNELL THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED AND REFER TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CENTER ABOUT.
FELL AYE FATES DOLLY.
DOLLY I DON.
DON AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE MORALE [inaudible]
ROTH RUBIO.
SO I SKINNER STONE NUMBER.
CASTING. SIX VOTES IN FAVOUR
EMILY'S ARE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU SO MOMENT -- WE'LL GO
TO AB FIFTY ONE FIFTY ONE SIX IN
CHIU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID CHIU.
DAVID SIR AND WE'LL WELCOME HIM
TO OUR COMMITTEE -- YOU HAVE THE
FLOOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COLLEAGUES I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF AB FIVE SIXTEEN
A BILL THAT WOULD REFORM A FEW
TELLING PRACTICES THAT HAVE
SEVERELY IMPACTED LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS.
LET ME FIRST START WITH A BIG
THANKS TO YOUR CHAIRMAN AND YOUR
STAFF MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR YOUR
WORK ON THE VERY SIGNIFICAN
AMENDMENTS THAT WE HAVE AGREED
TO TAKE.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR ENGAGEMENT ON THIS ISSUE IN
YOUR STAFF'S ENGAGEMENT. FOR
THIS PRESENTATION I'M GOING TO
BRIEFLY DESCRIBE WATER BILL
SEEKS TO DO.
WHAT OUR BILL DOES NOT DO
BECAUSE THERE BEEN A NUMBER OF
MISCONCEPTIONS ABOUT THE BILL
AND TO SUMMARIZE THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE TAKING?
FIRST WHAT ABOUT US.
EARLIER THIS YEAR THERE WAS A
STATEWIDE STUDY THAT CLEARLY
DOCUMENTED THE IMPACT OF THREE
TOWING GROUNDS WHICH I WILL FOR
TO HIS POVERTY TOES.
IF YOU CAN'T PAY FOR FIVE
PARKING TICKETS IF YOU CAN'T PAY
FOR AN OUTDATED CAR REGISTRATION
OR FOR A PRIVATE PARKING SPOT.
YOUR CAR CAN BE TOWED.
SINCE ALMOST HALF OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS DON'T HAVE A SPARE
FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS.
FAR LESS THAN THE AVERAGE COST
TO GET YOUR CAR OUT OF A TOW
YARD.
GETTING TOWED EQUALS ASSET
FORFEITURE YOU LOSE YOUR CAR YOU
LOSE YOUR ABILITY TO GET YOUR
JOB YOU LOSE YOUR JOB.
AND MANY INSTANCES YOU LOSE YOUR
ONLY ECONOMIC ASSET AND YOUR
ONLY FORM OF SHELTER.
THESE PROPERTY TOES OF
XCELERATED POVERTY AND
HOMELESSNESS.
IT ALSO TURNS OUT THE TOTAL
YARDS LOSE MONEY WITH THESE
PROVISIONS BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO
STOW THEY HAVE TO STORE CARS
BEFORE A LIEN AUCTION ALE.
AND THE AVERAGE STORAGE AND
LEANS SO COST FAR EXCEED THE
AVERAGE SALES PRICE OF THESE
TOWED CARS FOR SIMILAR REASONS
CITIES RUNNING THESE TOàN
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN LOSING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
THIS IS WHY WE ORIGINALLY
PROPOSED TO ELIMINATE THESE
PROVISIONS TO END THE CYCLE OF
POVERTY THAT'S NOT WORKING FOR
FAMILIES FOR TOW YARDS OR CITIES.
KNOWING JUST TAKE A MOMENT TO
EXPLAIN WHAT THE BILL DOES NOT
DO BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN QUITE A
BIT OF MISINFORMATION ABOUT THIS
BILL.
THERE BEEN SOME ADVOCATES FOR
CITIES HAVE SUGGESTED THAT
SOMEHOW THIS BILL AND STALLING.
THAT IS FALSE THERE ARE OVER
THIRTY GROUNDS TO TOW CARS UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW.
MOST HAVE TO DO WITH PUBLIC
SAFETY IN TRAFFIC FLOW WERE NOT
TOUCHING THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THESE.
SECONDLY THERE SOME CITIES THAT
HAVE SUGGESTED THAT WE ARE GOING
TO ALLOW ABANDONED CARS ON THE
STREET WITH THIS BILL.
THAT IS ALSO FALSE THERE IS A
SPECIFIC TOWING PROVISION THAT
ALLOWS CITIES TO TOW CARS THAT
ARE BANNED IN WRECKED
INOPERATIVE EXCEPT TRUCK.
WERE NOT TOUCHING THOSE
PROVISIONS.
YOU MAY HAVE ALSO HEARD THE
SUGGESTION THAT SOMEHOW WE ARE
REMOVING LOCAL CONTROL.
THAT'S A DOUBLE ALSE BECAUSE
THERE IS ANOTHER TOLL PROVISION
THAT WE'RE NOT TOUCHING WITH
THIS BILL THAT ALLOWS ANY CITY
TO PASS ANY LOCAL LAW TO REQUIRE
TOWING IN ANY CIRCUMSTANCE.
THIS BILL SUPPORTS PURE LOCAL
CONTROL.
LET ME CONCLUDE BY DISCUSSING
THE SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS THAT
WE TOOK.
OUR REGIONAL BILL VOTED ON BY
THE ASSEMBLY WOULD HAVE DELETED
THE THREE POVERTY TOWING
PROVISIONS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE.
AFTER NUMEROUS DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE CHAIRMAN AND MANY OF YOU
WITH AMENDED OR BILL FOR THIS
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER TO ONLY
DELETE ONE OF THE THREE TELLING
GROUNDS.
THE AMENDED VERSION OF OUR BILL
WOULD ALLOW CITIES TO CONTINUE
TO TELL FOR EXPIRED REGISTRATION.
THE MINUTE VERSION OF A BILL
WILL ALSO ALLOW CITIES TO
CONTINUE TO TOW CARS THAT HAVE
BEEN LEGALLY PARKED ON PUBLIC
STREETS.
CURRENT LAW SAYS A CAR TO BE
TOWED AFTER SEVENTY TWO HOURS
WITHOUT NOTICE SINCE MANY CITIES
TOLD US THAT THEY DON'T TELL
UNDER THIS LAW FOR AT LEAST A
WEEK OR LONGER.
AND SUPPORT PROVIDING NOTICE TO
CAR OWNERS BEFORE TELL.
ARMAMENTS WOULD ALLOW A CAR TO
BE TOWED AFTER NOTICE AND TEN
BUSINESS DAYS AND I WANT TO JUST
MAKE A NOTE.
I'VE HAD A CONVERSATION WITH AT
LEAST ONE OF YOU ABOUT THE TEN
DAY BUSINESS NOTICE AND I AM
PREPARED IF THIS IS THE WILL OF
THIS COMMITTEE. TO AMEND IT
FURTHER TO GO FROM TEN BUSINESS
DAYS TO HAVE A FIVE BUSINESS DAY
REQUIREMENT.
OUR BILL DOES MOVE TO AND TOES
FOR ONE PROVISION AND THAT IS
FOR UNPAID PARKING TICKETS WHICH
IS THE PUREST VERSION OF TELLING
SOMEONE TO COLLECT A MINOR DEBT.
I WOULD NOTE THAT OUR BILL DOES
NOT MAKE IT LEGAL NOT TO PAY
PARKING TICKETS IN FACT OUR BILL
WOULD ENSURE THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WOULD USE ALL
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE ALTERNATIVES
TO COLLECT UNPAID DEBTS THERE AT
LEAST. EIGHT IN STATUTE CHARGING
LATE PENALTY PAYMENTS
WITHHOLDING TAX RETURNS PLACING
REGISTRATION HOLDS SETTING DEBTS
TO COLLECTION AGENCIES OBTAINING
CIVIL JUDGMENTS LOVING BANK
ACCOUNTS GARNISHING WAGES
REPLACING MEANS.
BLESSING I WANT TO SAY IS.
THERE ARE STRONG CONSTITUTIONAL
ARGUMENTS THE TONE SOMEONE TO
CLICK TO MINOR DEBT VIOLATES THE
FOURTH AMENDMENT'S PROHIBITION
AGAINST THE SEIZURE PROPERTY THE
EIGHTH AMENDMENT'S PROHIBITION
AGAINST EXCESSIVE FINES.
THE FOURTEENTH AMENDMENT'S
PROHIBITION AGAINST THE
DEPRIVATION OF DUE PROCESS AND
EQUAL PROTECTION.
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND WITH ME
IN SUPPORT I'M NOT GOING TO TURN
IT OVER TO OUR WITNESSES.
WITNESSES IN FAVOR PLEASE GO
AHEAD LIMóN NAME IS GENET TOO
LOUDLY IN.
WHAT PUT THEM MIGRATED FROM
EARLIER -- MOUTH THERE.
THERE YOU GO.
CLICK THE BUTTON.
THIS ON GOING OKAY MY NAME IS
GENET DILLONLIAM.
AND I'M A I'M CURRENTLY A SENIOR
CITIZEN RESIDENT THAT LIVES IN
THE SUCH AS HOUSING.
IN OAKLAND COMMUNITY COME IN
OAKLAND.
MY CALL WAS -- TO ON MAY TWENTY
FOURTH TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN BY
AUTO PLUS TOWING. FOR A MOVE.
FOR UNPAID PARKING TICKETS I'M
SORRY A MILLINER WAS NOW.
GO RIGHT -- PROBLEM AND I CAN I
CAN AFFORD TO PAY THE TICKETS.
THE TOWING COMPANY DEMANDED MORE
THAN THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM
MY CAR TO BE RETURNED.
COULD AFFORD THESE FINES AND
FEES.
ALLOWS MY VEHICLE I HAVE HEARD
OF THE SIMS STORIES.
ABOUT YOUR FROM A NEIGHBOR'S.
THERE IS A STREET SWEEPING THE
SUITES STREET SWEEPER SIX DAYS A
WEEK.
WHICH MEANS WE ALL TOP WALK ON
ONE SIDE OF THE STREET WHICH
LEAVES YOU KNOW NOT ENOUGH
PARKING FOR EVERYBODY -- WHEN I
LOST MY CAR?
ALLOWS MY ONLY AT SAID ALLOWS
MOBILITY TO GO AND BUY
AFFORDABLE FOOD -- AT THE
GROCERY STORE AND I HAVE CHRONIC
PAIN FROM A WORK RELATED.
ENTERING.
WITHOUT MY CAR I LOSE MY ABILITY
TO TEN MEDICAL APPOINTMENTS AND
FINALLY ALLOWS MY VEHICLE THAT
ALLOWED ME TO PURSUE.
EDUCATION DEGREE AT MERRITT
COLLEGE -- AB. FIVE SIXTEEN
WOULD CHANGE THE LAW.
SO THE WORKING PEOPLE AND
SENIORS ARE NOT.
CONTINUOUSLY TRAPPED IN.
THERE IS SYSTEMS.
THE STRIP THEM OF THEIR
OPPORTUNITY AND WELL WE CANNOT
AFFORD THE HIGH.
TOWING FEES.
THAT STATE.
IS TRYING TO IMPOSE UPON US.
IN THAT VENUE I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
VOTE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FIVE SIXTEEN MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
CAROL WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY -- MANY OF
YOU'VE SEEN US AND COMMITTEES
BEFORE ANOTHER OF OUR LEGAL
SERVICE ADVOCATES OVER THE LAST
SIX YEARS WORKING ON THESE
ISSUES AROUND THE HIGH COST OF
FINES AND FEES AND THE IMPACTON
OUR LOW ON LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS.
THESE THESE IMPACTS THESE FINES
AND FEES BECAUSE SIGNIFICANT
HARDSHIP FOR OUR CLIENTS AS YOU
JUST HEARD DESCRIBED -- SHE'S
ONE OF JUST LITERALLY THOUSANDS
OF CLIENTS THAT WE HAVE SEEN IN
RECENT YEARS WHO HAVE EITHER HAD
THEIR LICENSE TAKEN IN TRAFFIC
COURT OR BEEN SUBJECT TO HAVING
THE CAR TAKEN AWAY FOR UNPAID
PARKING TICKETS.
AND IT MAKES OUR CLIENTS HAVE TO
CHOOSE DALY BETWEEN PAIN RANT
PUTTING FOOD ON THE TABLE OR
PAYING THE COST OF THESE TICKETS --
THE REPORTED ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
REFERENCE TOWED INTO DEBT
HIGHLIGHTS YET ANOTHER WAY IN
WHICH THESE PAUL THESE POLICIES
ARE HARMING THE POOR BY THE HIGH
COST OF THESE TICKETS.
ARE LITERALLY -- CAUSING US TO
SEE CARS THAT ARE BEING -- TOWED
FOR FIVE MORE PARKING TICKETS --
FOR A DMV REGISTRATION IT'S OUT
OF DATE OR ARE FOR BEING PART
FOR MORE THAN SEVENTY TWO HOURS
ON THE STREET.
THESE ARE THE THREE MOST
SIGNIFICANT REASONS THAT WE SAW
IN OUR RESEARCH THAT SHOWED THAT
WHEN A PERSON -- GOT THEIR CAR
TOWED THEY DID NOT GET IT BACK
WE DIDN'T CHOOSE THESE THREE
ITEMS AT RANDOM BUT INSTEAD VERY
MUCH IN SPECIFIC BECAUSE THESE
ARE THE THINGS THAT ARE TRULY
IMPACTING.
OUR CLIENTS -- SO AS WE SIT HERE
TODAY IT'S IT'S A LITTLE IT'S
YOU KNOW OF THE AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE BEING PROPOSED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
TO ARE SIGNIFICANT -- AND
FRANKLY A LITTLE BIT PAINFUL FOR
US BECAUSE THEY DO LIMIT THE
APPLICATION OF THE BILL AND IT
MEANS THAT NOT ALL OF THE FOLKS
THAT WE'RE HOPING TO BE ABLE TO
PROTECT IN THIS BILL THIS YEAR.
WE'LL GET THAT PROTECTION -- BUT
NONETHELESS EVEN WITH THOSE --
WE STILL THINK THIS IS A
SUBSTANTIAL STEP FORWARD FOR
SOME OF OUR CLIENTS THIS WILL
ALLOW THEM TO KEEP THEIR CARS
AND I WANT TO KNOW THAT WHEN OUR
CLIENTS HAVE THEIR CARS FOR MANY
OF THEM.
IT ACTUALLY PROVIDES THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET TO WORK AND
ACTUALLY PAY OFF FEES FINES AND
FEES AND ONE CARS GET TAKEN FROM
OUR CLIENTS LIKE THIS IT
pGOVERNMENTS TO BE ABLE TO
COLLECT REVENUES.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE STILL
STAND SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND
CHEN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A OF THE NEXT PICKERS
JUSTIFICATION WHO -- WHO THEY
ARE AN ORGANIZATION THEY
REPRESENT FAVOR OF IT?
THANK YOU ELLIE SATTLER FIANNA
BEHALF OF LAWYERS COMMITTEE FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS IN FAVOR OKAY OTHER
PEOPLE PLEASE.
FINALLY JANE WITH OF THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
BRIAN B. STAND WITH THE NATIONAL
UNION OF HEALTH CARE WORKERS IN
SUPPORT. FIFTY ONE WITH A C. R.
U. CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF OUR
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS
IN SUPPORT.
ERIN FOR BATH PRIVATE CITIZEN IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON GLASSER SAUDIA ON
BEHALF OF PUBLIC COUNCIL IN LOS
ANGELES IN SUPPORT -- CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
MY SECOND SALAS ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CHRIS FOR SIGNS OF THE CHIRLA
COLLEGE FREEMAN IMMIGRANTRIGHTS
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST IMMIGRANTS
ORGANIZATION STRONG SUPPORT.
JIM WEINBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
TO CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
AND WHEN MATHIS WITH UNITED
DOMESTIC WORKERS ASKED M LOCAL
THIRTY NINE THIRTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MY ANGER I'M A SILLY OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT SPONSOR.
JESSICA CENTER ON BEHALF OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES AND THE
STRONGER CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES
NETWORK IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
OKAY.
OTHER SPEAKERS IN FAVOR PLEASE --
SAY NINE WILL HAVE THE
OPPOSITION CO FOR COME ON
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
YOU GUYS.
OR YOU CAN ASK.
THERE ARE NO -- WEATHER COMING
UP.
ASSEMBLYMAN COULD YOU
ASSEMBLYMAN CAN YOU CLARIFY.
THE CHANGES YOU'RE AGREEING TO
TODAY.
WELL CERTAINLY SO.
THE CHANGES THAT OF AN IMPRINT
FOR THE LAST FEW DAYS. ONE WE
ARE NOT GOING TO MOVE TO DELETE
THE PROVISIONS THAT HAVE TO DO
WITH EXPIRED REGISTRATION SO THE
REALLY THREE GROUNDS -- THAT WE
WERE TRYING TO IMPACT WITH THE
VERSION THAT CAME FROM THE
ASSEMBLY SO ONE OF THE GROUNDS.
WE WERE NOT GOING TO BE MOVING
ON SO WILL BE DELETING THOSE
PROVISIONS.
WHEN IT COMES -- TO THE RULES
AROUND CARS ADMIN LEGALLY PARKED
ON PUBLIC STREETS CURRENT LAW
SAYS A CAR HAS TO BE TOWED AFTER
SEVENTY TWO HOURS WITHOUT NOTICE.
AND AGAIN BECAUSE A LOT OF
CITIES TOLD US THAT THEY
TYPICALLY DON'T TALK -- TO UNDER
THIS OFFER AT LEAST A WEEK OR
LONGER AND SUPPORT PROVIDING
NOTICED THE MEMBERS WE HAVE IN
FRONT OF THE COMMITTEE WOULD
ALLOW A CAR TO BE TOWED AFTER.
NOTICE AND TEN BUSINESS DAYS I
HAVE CIRCULATED TO THE
MEMBERSHIP BECAUSE IT WAS
REQUESTED BY AT LEAST ONE OF
YOUR MEMBERS THAT WE CONSIDER
TAKING TEN BUSINESS DAYS AND
HAVING THAT GO DOWN TO FIVE
BUSINESS DAYS NOT PREPARED TO
TAKE THAT.
IF THAT IS SOMETHING THAT THIS
COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO DO AND
THAT OUR BILL DOES NOT -- WE ARE
NOT AMENDING -- THE LANGUAGE
THAT WE HAD IN THE ORIGINAL
ASSEMBLY BILL AROUND TOES FOR
UNPAID PARKING TICKETS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
GO OVER THAT SO EVERYBODY'S KIND
OF UNDERSTANDS.
OKAY -- LET'S HEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITION.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU -- GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
RIGHT WE DO HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES --
OVER GRATEFUL THAT THE AUTHOR
HAS LEFT THE DOOR OPEN FOR
ONGOING DISCUSSIONS WITH FOR AB --
FIVE ONE SIX THE LEAGUE MUST
REGRETFULLY REMAIN OPPOSED TO AB
FIVE ONE SIX AS AMENDED -- I
THINK WE WOULD CONTINUE HAVE
CONCERNS IN WITH THE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS -- AND WE WOULD
REALLY LIKE TO PARTICIPATE IN
THOSE DSCUSSIONS DIRECTLY WITH
THE AUTHOR -- MORE CLOSELY --
AND I THINK WE HAVE SOME TIME
FOR THAT -- IF IF THE YOU KNOW
IF IF -- IF THAT'S THE WILL THE
CHAIR -- AND THE COMMITTEE -- AB
FIVE WAS ONE SIX AND IN OUR VIEW
WILL HURT THE ABILITY FOR THE
GOVERNMENTS TO PROPERLY MANAGE
OUR LOCAL STREETS -- AND THE
PUBLIC RIGHT OF WAY -- CITIES
HAVE TO HAVE THE RIGHT TOOLS TO
MANAGE AND BALANCE THE PARKING
NEEDS FOR EVERYONE -- IN OUR
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING OUR
RESIDENTS BUSINESSES VISITORS --
AND COMMUTERS.
I THOUGHT TO BE CLEAR A CITIES
ALLOW FOR FOLKS TO PARK ON
PUBLIC STREETS BUT WE LET ME
SHORT OR LONG TERM STORAGE.
A PRIVATE VHICLES ON PUBLIC
STREETS -- THIS IS ESSENTIAL FOR
RESIDENTS TO GET HOME --
BUSINESS IS THAT OUR BUSINESS IS
TO HAVE A STEADY FLOW OF
CUSTOMERS -- OUR VISITORS TO
HAVE -- TO SEE THEIR FAMILIES
AND VISIT THEIR FAMILIES -- AND
TO ENJOY OUR CITIES AND TO
PREVENT BLIGHT AND OTHER PUBLIC
SAFETY HAZARDS -- ENFORCEMENT --
IN A TIMELY SEVENTY TWO HOUR
MATTER -- IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT -- INNER DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES -- TO ADDRESS BLIGHT
AND THE RISK -- TO PUBLIC SAFETY
THAT THIS BILL CREATES -- AND SO
FOR THOSE REASONS WE URGE YOUR
NOVO -- ON AB FIVE ONE SIX TODAY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU. TO TURN MEMBERS
MATTHEW HARD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
I'M HERE TO SPEAK ABOUT THE
IMPACT THIS HAS ON OUR
BUSINESSES WE WORK WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL COUNCIL OF
SHOPPING CENTERS AS WELL AS SOME
OTHER.
GROUPS THAT MANAGE PROPERTIES
FOR RETAIL AND FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND MANY OF OUR
CONGESTED AREAS AND CITIES.
LARGE CITIES AND SMALL CITIES
ALIKE IF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ISN'T ABLE TO MANAGE ITS PARKING
IN A MANNER IT WILL HAVE A HUGE
AND NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THOSE
SMALL BUSINESSES.
AND THOSE COMPANIES THAT RELY ON
A LOT OF TURN AROUND OF CARS
BEING ABLE TO COME IN PARK.
GET THEIR BUSINESS DONE AND MOVE
OUT OF THERE THERE'S A LOT OF A
MINUTE SOME FROM THE COMMITTEE
TODAY THAT I CAN'T SPEAK TO ONE
FORTUNATELY I HAVEN'T SEEN THOSE.
WHO WERE SPEAKING -- TO THE BILL
AS IT CAME INTO THE COMMITTEE
WERE PARTICULARLY CONCERNED WITH
THE IN CONCERN WITH THE
DISINCENTIVE ISING.
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND PEOPLE
GETTING PARKING TICKETS IF
YOU'RE NOT GETTING YOUR CAR --
TOWED BECAUSE YOU'RE GETTING
PARKING TICKETS WHAT'S TO STOP
YOU FROM PARKING ANYWHERE YOU
WANT GETTING A TICKET AND JUST
MOVING ON WITH YOUR DAY THAT'S A
THAT'S A BIG ISSUE WE HAVE --
THIS COMMITTEE IN THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT A DECADE AGO
DID PASSED SOME -- TOWING REFORM
WHICH HAD DIRECT IMPACT ON US
AND WE SEE THOSE NEGATIVE
IMPACTS EVERY DAY AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW YOU CAN PARK AND PRIVATE
PARKING LOTS RIGHT NOW FOR UP TO
ONE HOUR -- AND WE REGULARLY SEE
EVEN WITHOUT BEING TOWED WE
REGULARLY SEE EVEN IN THOSE
PARKING LOTS WORD SIGN VERY
CLEARLY NOT TO PARK THERE PEOPLE
WILL COME IN AND AND PARK THE
VEHICLE THEN LEAVE IT THERE FOR
ONE HOUR -- KNOWING THAT THERE'S
NOTHING THAT CAN BE DONE ABOUT
IT SO WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
IMPACT HERE ON A MUCH BROADER
SCALE ON ALL THE PUBLIC STREETS.
FOR THOSE REASONS WE HOPE THAT
YOU'LL.
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU SIR ONE
MORE SPEAKER.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOE
COLLINS I REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION A LICENSE
REPOSSESSIONS WERE OPPOSE THIS
BILL HEY.
WE HAVE A UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE ON
HOW THINGS WORK IN A TOW YARD
BECAUSE IT'S OUR INDUSTRY THAT'S
HIRED. TO GET A CAR OUT OF THE
TOW YARD ON BEHALF OF THE
REGISTERED OWNER OR LEGAL OWNER.
OFTENTIMES THE PAYMENT THAT IS
DUE IS PUT ON THE BACK END.
OF THAT PERSON'S CAR NOTES THEY
CAN MAKE THEIR PAYMENTS AND
STILL KEEP THEIR CAR.
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE.
WE DON'T HEAR ANYTHING
ADDRESSING HOW FEES ARE CHARGED
A TOW YARD AND I'LL EXPLAIN THAT
TO YOU.
MOST PEOPLE HAVE NO IDEA WHEN
THEY GO TO A TOW YARD WHAT
THEY'RE PAYING THERE'S NO
PRICING MATRIX.
THERE IS A BOARD THAT SAYS YOU
PAY X. Y. Z. BUT WHEN YOU LOOK
AT YOUR PAY OUT RECEIPT IT'S
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT.
THE CONSUMERS USUALLY WILL PAY
3240% MORE I KNOW THIS BECAUSE
AS A REPOSSESSION AGENCY I SEE
OUR PARK ARE PAID OUT RECEIPTS
AND WE'RE CONSTANTLY CHALLENGING
THE FEES.
WHETHER IT'S THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS
HERE A HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS THERE TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS SOMEWHERE
ELSE.
IN FACT OFTENTIMES TOWARDS WILL
CHARGE YOU AN HOURLY RATE NO
TACK ON THREE HOURS AS OPPOSED
TO JUST THE ONE WHICH IS IN THE
CONTRACT.
BUT NOBODY'S ADDRESSING THE
ISSUE OF HOW THE FEES ARE
CHARGING HOW A CONSUMER THE
LEAST SOPHISTICATED CONSUMER
WOULD ACTUALLY KNOW IF YOU'RE
PAYING LEGAL A LOT OF MONEY THAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO PAY.
NOW WE'VE OFFERED AMENDMENTS
INCLUDING ONE THAT SAYS YOU CAN
USE A DEBIT CARD BECAUSE MOST
PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE IS HE HAD A
CAR TOWED HE CAN'T USE ANYTHING
OTHER THAN A CREDIT CARD.
AND MOST PEOPLE HAVE DEBIT CARDS
BUT THE CODE ONLY ADDRESSES THAT
YOU CAN USE.
A CREDIT CARD SO THE AVERAGE
PERSON WHO SHOWS UP WITH THEIR
DEBIT CARD IS TURNED AWAY.
NOW WE'VE OFFERED AN AMENDMENT
SO YOU'D BE ALLOWED TO USE A
DEBIT CARD.
WE HAVEN'T HEARD ANYTHING BACK
YET -- COST RECOVERY FEES THE
CITY'S CHARGE OF TWENTY TWO A
FIFTY POINT FIVE THEY CAN
RECRUIT COVER THE COST. FOR THE
TOWING AND STORAGE OF THE
VEHICLE HIT SOME CITIES WILL
CHARGE FIVE TIMES MORE THAN
THEIR COST.
THIS IS WHAT PREVENTS PEOPLE
FROM GETTING THE CAR BACK IT'S
EVERYBODY'S TKING A BITE OUT OF
THEM BEFORE THEY EVER GET TO THE
TOW YARD THEY HAVE NO MONEY LEFT.
WE'VE OFFERED NUMEROUS SOLUTIONS
AND WERE OPEN. TO HAVE MORE
DIALOGUE BUT AT THIS POINT IN
TIME WE HAVE TO OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU AND CLEAR -- THE OTHER
PEOPLE THAT OPPOSE NAME AND NOW
ORGANIZATION PLEASE ONLY.
I GRAY CASE HERE ABOUT HALF OF
THE NATIONAL PUBLIC SAFETY
TRANSPORTATION ASSOCIATION
OPPOSITION ABOUT.
JONATHAN CLAY ON BEHALF THE CITY
EVEN SENATORS IN OPPOSITION.
HOLDEN MEASURE BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF WEST HOLLYWOOD WE'VE
SUBMITTED SOME AMENDMENTS AND A
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR ON ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU.
ELLERY NEVER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WERE IN
OPPOSITION.
I'M NOT A LOT ALTHOUGH ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF SAN JOSE IN
OPPOSITION.
PURUS ON BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF
BURBANK GLENDALE MARIETTA AND
PASADENA ALL IN OPPOSITION.
MORE TOP ON BEHALF THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAMBERS MATTHEW SO I
REALLY ONLY HAVE THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE PROTECTIVE LEAGUE IN THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLICPARKING
ASSOCIATION BOTH OPPOSED THANK
YOU.
VETERAN JASON BRIAN UP WE HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA DOWNTOWN
ASSOCIATION WERE POST.
SCHERING GUNS ALL OF HIS ON
BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF BEAUMONT
AT HIS END UP AS IT.
WERE OPPOSED AND ALSO -- ON
BEHALF OF OAKLAND VICE MAYOR
LARRY READ AND COUNCILMEMBER
LAUREN TAYLOR WHO HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION THANK
YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BALKANS OFFICER TODAY
ME UP THE CITY'S AWAKE WITH
THOUSAND OAKS INDIAN WELLS GOING
DORO LORADO RANCHO CUCAMONGA
PALMDALE PALM DESERT AND
TORRANCE ALL OPPOSED.
THIS CHAIR MEMBERS TRUST BUCKLEY
ON BEHALF TO SEE IF SACRAMENTO
IN OPPOSITION.
TONY BE WITH THE A CALIFORNIA
PURPOSE OCEAN HEARING
OPPOSITIONAL.
CARROL HUTCHINSON LOS ANGELES
CITY SUNLAND HUNGER NEIGHBORHOOD
COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION.
BUT A GRANT VICE PRESIDENT THE
SUNLAND HUNG A NEIGHBOR COUNCIL
A COMMUNITY IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES WE DROVE HER FROM LOS
ANGELES TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
COMMUNITY WAS REPRESENTED TO LET
YOU KNOW.
WE ARE AGAINST AB FIVE SIXTEEN
THANK YOU.
MR TURN MEMBER SYLVIA'S ALICIA
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND IN
OPPOSITION.
HI SEAN THOSE ABOUT THE NATIONAL
FEDERATION INDEPENDENT BUSINESS
AND ARE TWENTY THOUSAND SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
MR MEMBERS RAINY PERRY WITH
THEIR ARENA SUCH HITS OVER HALF
A POOR ALCOR POST.
GEN MEMBERS JONATHON FELDMAN THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION ALSO REGISTERING
OPPOSITION ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF LONG BEACH CITY RIVERSIDE AND
THE CITY OF SAN CARLOS.
SECURE MEMBERS ANDREW AND WE
WOULD CHARGE -- ANTS WE HEAR ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS WITH RICH RECENTLY ADOPTED
OPPOSE POSITION ON THIS MEASURE.
OKAY WELL -- IN TERMS OF THE
PROCESS WE HAVE A BILL ON AUG
SEPT YOUR AMENDMENTS FOR
DISCUSSION AND WILL TURN IT OVER.
TO QUESTIONS FROM OUR COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO HAS
SOME QUESTIONS.
FOR I JUST US FOR SENATOR BUT WE
GET CONFUSED ALL THE TIME.
THAT'S MY CIVIL RIGHTS -- IT'S
OKAY ONE THANK YOU SO MUCH I WE
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT A COUPLE
OF THINGS YOU KNOW AS I I WAS --
LOCAL COUNCIL MEMBER AND I
SERVED ALSO THIRTEEN YEARS SO.
I HAD A LOT OF CONCERNS GOING
INTO THIS DISCUSSION AND I'M
REALLY THANKFUL TO THE AUTHOR
THAT HE SAT DOWN WITH ME AND TRY
TO ADDRESS ON MY CONCERNS AND
THAT OF MY COMMUNITIES AND MY
POLICE OFFICERS WHITE.
VALUE THEIR OPINION AND AND AND
AGAIN BEING FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT I UNDERSTAND THAT --
THE FEAR OF LOSING THE LOCAL
CONTROL.
BUT I WANT TO POINT OUT JUST --
THREE THINGS THAT WERE REALLY
THE BIGGEST CONCERN AND I KNOW
THAT AS A LOCAL COUNCIL MEMBER I
HAVE PUT SOME ORDINANCE IN PLACE
AS IT. TO TO TOWING AND SO I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT CITIES
CAN STILL KEEP THEIR LOCAL
ORDINANCE AND THAT WOULD NOT
CHANGE.
SO I WANT TO POINT OUT TO ONE
SECTION THAT STILL IN THE BILL
JUST TO CLARIFY FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE ESPECIALLY IN MY
COMMUNITIES.
I AND THAT IS SECTION TWO TWO
SIX FIVE ONE OF THE VEHICLE CODE
THAT STATE THAT ALL CITIES CAN
STILL TOTAL A CAR IF IT'S PARKED
ARE LEFT STANDING WERE LOCAL
AUTHORITIES.
BY RESOLUTION ORDINANCE HAVE
PROHIBITED PARKING AND HAVE
AUTHORIZED THE REMOVAL OF THE
VEHICLE SO.
MY ORDINANCE THAT I PUT IN PLACE
FOR TWENTY CAN YOU CLARIFY IS
THAT STONE PLEASE ANSWER IS YES
AND FIRST OF ALL LET ME
APPRECIATE YOUR ENGAGEMENT WITH
US ON THIS AND THERE'S NOTHING
THIS BILL THAT WOULD IMPACT THE
LOCAL RUBIO ORDINANCES THAT YOU
HAVE PUT INTO PLACE AROUND.
SENATOR RUBIO.
SENATOR RICK WELL THESE ARE AND
YOU WERE ON THE CITY COUNCIL I
MAN THAT'S WHY REFER TO THEM
THAT WAY -- THE VEHICLE CODE
SECTION THAT YOU REFERENCED
ALLOWS ANY CITY TO PASS ANY
LOCAL RESOLUTION ORDINANCE
AROUND TELLING AND LET ME.
STATE SOMETHING BECAUSE I THINK
IT HAS BEEN ON CLEAR WITH A LOT
OF CITIES IN THEIR UNDERSTAND IN
THIS BILL.
THIS WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING IS NOT
FOR A STATE TO TOWING POLICY
THAT WOULD PREEMPT LOCAL LOS
WHAT WE'RE WHAT WE'RE SUGGESTING
IS THAT WE DELETE.
CERTAIN TOWING PROVISIONS SO
THAT -- THEY'RE OFF THE BOOKS
BUT BUT THIS OTHER PROVISION
THAT WE JUST REFER TO WOULD
ALLOW ANY CITY TO PASS ANY LOCAL
TOWING ORDINANCE TO DEAL WITH
ANY LOCAL CIRCUMSTANCE.
YOU SEE FIT SELECT IN EXAMPLE --
THE ONLY TOàN PROVISION THAT AT
THIS POINT THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WE'VE TAKEN WOULD ALLOW TO WHICH
WE'RE ASKING YOU TO SUPPORT.
IS THE IDEA THAT IF YOU HAVE
FIVE MORE PARKING TICKETS TOàN
SHOULD NOT BE THE OPTION THAT
CITIES USED TO GO OUT TO THEIR
MANY OTHER.
WAYS THAT YOU CAN GO AFTER
PEOPLE AND I LISTED EIGHT OTHER
WAYS THAT YOU CAN USE AS A CITY
TO GO AFTER YOU.
BUT WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS AS A
STATE POLICY IT SHOULD NOT BE AN
AUTOMATIC RULE BUT IF YOU'RE
LOCAL CITY OF ANY OF YOUR LOCAL
CITIES BELIEVE THAT SHOULD BE
THE CASE.
YOU COULD PASS A LOCAL LAW THAT
SAYS IN THE CITY OF TAX.
IF YOU HAVE FIVE OR MORE PARKING
TICKETS YOUR CAR CAN BE TOWED.
SO THIS IS A PURE LOCAL CONTROL
MEASURE -- SO THE THE LONG
WINDED ANSWER YOUR QUESTION BUT
YES THE RULES THAT YOU PUT IN
PLACE WOULD REMAIN IN PLACE.
THANK YOU SO THAT WAS A MAJOR
CONCERN AGAIN COMING FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT I WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL MY CITIES ALL MY
ENFORCEMENT WHO AGAIN.
I VALUE VERY DEEPLY.
WOULD FEEL CONFIDENT ENOUGH THAT
OUR LOCAL ORDINANCE WAS STILL BE
IN PLACE AND THEY COULD STILL DO
THEIR JOB -- NOW AS A LOCAL
COUNCIL MEMBER I ALSO STRUGGLED
VERY MUCH ON MAKING SURE THAT MY
COMMITTEE WAS SAFE CLEAN
AESTHETICALLY PLEASING BUT ALSO.
BALANCING THE FACT THAT THERE
ARE SOME PEOPLE NOW DAYS THAT
ARE FALLING ON HARD TIMES AND
SOMETIMES IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
FOR THEM TO GET THE CARS OUT.
WE DEALT WITH A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT LOST THEIR CARS DUE TO
THEIR INABILITY TO TO TAKE THEIR
CARS OUTSELL SO TAUGHT ALWAYS A
BALANCING ACT AND SO.
I DO APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR ONCE
AGAIN SITTING DOWN WITH ME
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT IT WAS A
LONGER TERM.
AND HE WAS WILLING TO BRING IT
DOWN TO FIVE DAYS AND TYPICALLY
IT I CAN TELL YOU AS A LOCAL
COUNCIL MEMBER IT WOULD TAKE US
A COUPLE OF DAYS TO GET THE CAR
ANYWAY SO WE'RE JUST MAKING IT
UP.
PUTTING IN A PLACE MAKING SURE
THAT PEOPLE HAVE A LITTLE BIT
MORE TIME.
TO DEAL WITH THEIR CIRCUMSTANCE
WHETHER IT IS GETTING SOMEONE TO
HELP THEM IN A MOVE THEIR CAR OR
WHATEVER IT MAY BE SO.
I THINK THAT THIS BILL HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANT ME.
CHANGE.
AS IT STARTED IN THE ASSEMBLY
WHICH I WASN'T GONNA SUPPORT BUT
GIVEN THE FACT THAT YOU SAT DOWN
WITH US WHAT IS WITH ME.
AND YOU'VE COME SUCH A LONG WAY
FROM THE BEGINNING THIS BILL I
WILL BE SUPPORTING IT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THOSE CHANGES
THANK AND I JUST WANT TO ALSO
GIVE YOU CREDIT SENATOR -- WE
SPOKE ABOUT THE TEN DAY.
LIMITATION THAT WERE IN THE
ORIGINAL MOMENTS ANDIT WAS
THROUGH THE CONVERSATION YOU
SAID YOU WERE MORE COMFORTABLE
WITH FIVE DAYS AND AGAIN THAT
WAS WHY WE HAVE CIRCULATED THAT
A MOMENT HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU.
CORRECT THANK YOU SO AT IN TERMS
OF THE BILL WERE VOTING ON WILL
ACCEPT THOSE AMENDMENTS AS WELL
AS YOUR OTHER AMENDMENTS.
AS THE FIVE WORKING DAY.
REQUIREMENTS BY BUSINESS EVER
COURT OKAY SO THAT'S THE BILL ON
THE FLOOR -- OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM OTHER MEMBERS [inaudible]
OKAY.
WE ARE MOTIONS ARE YOU WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE PLEASE.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT THE
CONVERSATION A LET ME SAY I KNOW --
THERE IS STILL SOME OPPOSITION
AND WE HAVE HAD NUMEROUS
MEETINGS WITH MANY CITIES
INCLUDING THE LEAGUE OF CITIES
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT AND OTHERS.
ARE TO CONTINUE TO MAKE THIS A
BETTER BILL AND I'M COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO DO THAT -- AND LET
ME ALSO SAY THAT I VERY MUCH
AGREE WE ALL SHARE THE GOAL OF
ENSURING PUBLIC SAFETY AND
ASSURING TRAFFIC FLOW SO THERE'S
NOTHING.
ABOUT THIS THAT IS MEANT TO
IMPACT THAT -- AS I THINK YOU
HEARD FROM OUR COALITION WE HAVE
AMENDED THE SIGNIFICANTLY -- I
WILL SHARE WITH YOU THAT WE HAD
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHETHER WE
SHOULD -- CONTINUE TO YEAR
CONVERSATION WITHOUT MAKING
AMENDMENTS BUT FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO MOVE FORWARD
ON WHAT WE CAN AGREE WITH.
AND I THINK THAT IS WHAT YOU
HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU AND THAT'S
WHAT WE ASK YOU TO DO.
THE FINAL THING I WOULD SAY IS
WE ALL NOW REGARDS OF WHICH SIDE
OF THE AISLE WE ARE ON THAT THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES CALIFORNIA'S
FACING AT THIS TIME IS AROUND
INCOME INEQUALITY.
IT'S AROUND HOMELESSNESS IT'S
RUN STRUGGLES INVOLVING PEOPLE
WHO ARE POOR.
AND AS WE HAVE.
SIGNIFICANTLY AMENDED THIS WE DO
THINK THAT THESE ARE PROVISIONS
THAT WILL HELP IMPACT THAT
WITHOUT IMPACTING PUBLIC SAFETY
AND TRAFFIC FLOW AND FOR THOSE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT [inaudible]
OKAY -- WE HAVE A MOTION ON THIS
BILL [inaudible]
THE MOTION -- OKAY -- WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR.
I WANT TO MAKE A STATEMENT FIRST
HOWEVER -- I WANT TO THANK --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU FOR THE
WORK HE DID AND THE EFFORTS ON
THIS BILL.
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY HOWEVER I WANT TO NOTE.
THAT SHOULD THIS BILL PASS OUT.
OF THIS COMMITTEE.
I'D LIKE YOU TO CONSIDER --
PROVIDING A SOFT LANDING FOR
THOSE MOST IN NEED.
NO AMENDED VERSION STARTS TO
ADDRESS SEVERAL OF THE
SIGNIFICANT ISSUES OUR LOCAL
AGENCY AND LAW ENFORCEMENT HAVE
WITH THIS MEASURE.
BUT MUCH MORE WORK NEEDS TO BE
DONE.
FINDING A LOCATION WHERE LOW
INCOME IN HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
HAVE A SAFE PLACE TO PARK.
IS A KEY.
WE CAN'T JUST KEEP ROUSTING THEM
OUT OF PARKING PLACES WE HAVE TO
FIND A PLACE FOR THEM TO PARK.
AND THAT INCLUDES A LOCATION
WHERE PERSON WILL NOT BE WORRIED
ABOUT HAVING THEIR VEHICLE TOWED --
I I'M A I'M REALLY APPRECIATIVE
OF OF A ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE.
FOR AB -- THREE THREE ZERO WHICH
IS A SAFE PLACE TO PARK BILL.
CREATES -- OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CITIES TO CREATE THESE --
PARKING AREAS -- OF VARIOUS
CITIES HAVE STARTED TO DO THIS
KIND OF THING AND I THINK WE
OUGHT TO ENCOURAGE THAT.
HOWEVER WE SHOULD BE TAKING WE
SHOULD NOT BE TAKEN AWAY TOOLS
AWAY FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT TO TO
ADDRESS -- ILLEGAL PARKING AND
OR THEIR LOCAL ISSUES BUT MAY BE
ASSISTING THEM ON THIS PROBLEM
SO I THINK.
THIS BILL IS A GOOD BILL THE WAY
WE HAVE IN A MINUTE BUT I THINK
THERE'S THESE OTHER ISSUES.
THAT PROBABLY.
IN PREPARATION.
FOR THE BILL GOING FORWARD AND
ALSO ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE'S
BILL GOING FORWARD WHICH WE
HEARD IN THE GOVERNMENT FINANCE
COMMITTEE OF LAST WEEK -- WE
WANT TO HAVE THESE BILLS GO
TOGETHER AS BABY POSSIBLY A
JOINT SOLUTION. TO WORK TOGETHER
ON SO IF YOU COULD -- WORK ON
THAT IN THE FUTURE -- I WILL
SUPPORT THAT SO OUT OF SUPPORT
THE BILL AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU OF COURSE HAVE BEEN
ENGAGED WITH YOU SO WILL CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE SIXTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY.
CENTER ABOUT.
WELL I BATES.
DALI.
DALI AYE DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI AYE GALGIANI
AYE [inaudible]
MCGUIRE MORALE.
ROTH RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER STONE.
STONE NO I'M BURKE CASKEY.
YOUR FIVE LOS OF A REALLY THE
ROLE PERHAPS IN MEMBERS STILL BE
THERE IN OTHER COMMITTEES AT THE
TIME THANK YOU SIR -- OKAY --
OKAY WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN IS AB -- FOURTEEN TWENTY
FOUR YOU HAVE THE FLOOR FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND IF IF IT'S
ALRIGHT WITH YOU I'D LOVE TO
PLAY A POOR MAN'S TALK GLORIA.
INTRODUCED AB FOURTEEN THIRTEEN
FIRST YOU HAVE THE FLOOR FOR
THAT BILL AND SUBSTITUTION OF
OUR THE STEAM ASSEMLY MEMBER
GLORIA THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
AND THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT AB FOURTEEN THIRTEEN
TODAY ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GLORIA.
YOU KNOW HOW DIVERSE CAL WE KNOW
HOW DIVERSE CALIFORNIA IS AND WE
OFTEN HEAR ABOUT THE UNIQUE IN
VARYING NEEDS BETWEEN NORTHERN
AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA OR
COASTAL AND INLAND COMMUNITIES.
FOR THOSE OF US THAT COME FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WE KNOW THOSE
DIFFERENCES EXIST EVEN WITHIN
THE SMALLER JURISDICTIONS THAT
WE REPRESENT.
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
TRANSPORTATION.
AS LOCAL JR JURISDICTIONS PLAN
FOR TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS
PROGRESS IS OFTEN STYMIED WHEN
THE NEEDS OF ONE NEIGHBORHOOD OR
CITY DIFFER FROM THE NEEDS OF
ITS NEIGHBORING COMMUNITY.
UNFORTUNATELY NEITHER SUB REGION
REALIZES ANY BENEFIT AND THE
SAME FEELING INFRASTRUCTURE
WHETHER BE TRANSIT A ROAD REPAIR
GOES WITHOUT IMPROVEMENTS FOR
DECADES.
AB FOURTEEN THIRTEEN SIX TO
CHANGE THAT BY ALLOWING LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITIES THE
ABILITY TO ADVANCE IMPROVEMENT
PROJECTS BY SUBREGION.
SUBREGIONS THAT HAVE SHOWN A
DESIRE TO GET PAST THE POLITICAL
GRIDLOCK IN AN EFFORT TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN SEVERAL
TRANSPORTATION MEASURES APPEARED
ON BALLOTS ACROSS THE STATE.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN SIX
PASSED IN EIGHT FAILED.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THREE
PASSED INTO FAILED.
HOWEVER IN THOSE THAT FAILED WE
SAW EVIDENCE OF CORRIDORS OF
CONSTITUENCIES THAT SUPPORTED
THE MEASURE. FOR EXAMPLE IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING MEASURES IN CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY IN PLASTER COUNTY CAME
WITHIN PERCENTAGE POINTS OF
MEETING THE 66% PERCENT
THRESHOLD.
NEEDED FOR SALES TAX INCREASES
DESPITE LARGE CONCENTRATIONS OF
SUPPORT.
THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE THE
VOTER APPROVAL APPROVAL
THRESHOLD.
UNDER THIS BILL IF A FUNDING
MEASURE IS APPROVED BY THE
REQUIRED NUMBER VOTERS.
COMMUNITIES ARE BEING SHORT THAT
THE DECISION TO TAX THEMSELVES
WOULD NOT BE IN VAIN AS THE
REVENUES GENERATED FROM THE
APPROVED SALES TAX WOULD BE
AVAILABLE ONLY TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES.
LOCAL TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
MEASURES ALLOW LOCAL LEADERS TO
HAVE GREATER CONTROL UNCERTAINTY
OVER TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDS.
BY ENABLING.
LOCALS TO GENERATE SELF HELP
REVENUE THOSE IMPROVEMENT
DOLLARS GO TO EVEN FURTHER WHEN
THEY'RE ABLE TO PULL STATE
GRANTS WHICH MAY REQUIRE SELF
SUSTAINING SOURCES OF FUNDING AS
A CONDITION OF ELIGIBILITY.
WITH CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE LABOR
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE -- AND TODAY I
HAVE ROSE -- MAYOR JOHN ALLARD
AND JOE FILL BORJA ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JOHN ALLARD AND CURRENTLY THE
MEMBER THE MAYOR OF THE CITY OF
ROSEVILLE I'M ALSO A BUSINESS
OWNER IN PLASTER COUNTY.
I'LL KEEP IT SHORT I'M JUST HERE
TODAY TO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
THIRTEEN THANK YOU.
HUNDREDS OF FOR TO THE CDC
REPRESENTED FUND IS HERE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS IF THERE'S A
TECHNICAL ISSUE THAT ARISES
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR BELL.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS JOE FULL BORE HOW I'M WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION.
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND STAFF FOR HIM THIS
BILL AND FOR SOMEONE MEMBERS
GLORIA AND SPECIALLY MISTER
BERMAN.
WHAT'S YOUR HEADING TO SUFFER TO
PROVIDE OUR LOCAL REGIONAL
PARTNERS ADDITIONAL TOOLS
ADDRESS MUCH NEEDED FUNDING FOR
TRANSPORTATION.
ALTHOUGH SB ONE PROVIDES
CRITICAL INCREASES IN REVENUE
MANY OF OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE STILL FACE
ONGOING FUNDING SHORTFALS TO
MEET THEIR TRANSPORTATION NEEDS.
THE FINANCING CONCEPT OF THIS
BILL COULD PAVE WAY FOR THESE
AGENCIES TO HAVE ADDITIONAL
RELIABLE INSUFFICIENT FUNDING TO
ADDRESS OUR COMMUNITY
TRANSPORTATION NEEDS AND PROVIDE
FOR SAFETY CONGESTION.
AND ADDRESSING THEIR
ENVIRONMENTAL ECONOMIC.
AND SAFETY GOALS RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE AND TAKE YOUR TIME.
OTHERS SPEAKERS PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR TURN MEMBERS
CAROLING ON BEHALF OF THE SOLANO
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
AND IN SUPPORT SAY THANK YOU.
THANK.
ROSS BUCKLEY ON BEHALF OF RETURN
VENTURA COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION SUPPORT.
BILL JOY PLASTER COUNTY WE
AREN'T SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
OTHER SUPPORTERS.
WE DON'T SEE ANY SO HOW ABOUT
OPPOSITION.
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
THE OPPOSITION I DON'T SEE ANY
ARGUE.
OKAY -- QUESTIONS FROM OUR
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
QUESTIONS -- ANY NO QUESTIONS TO
HAVE A MOTION FOR THIS BILL.
OKAY WHERE MOTION THIS IS A FOR
THE MEMBERS -- FOURTEEN THIRTEEN
A. B. FOURTEEN THIRTEEN FROM.
SO MEMBER GLORIA AND CAN YOU
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
FOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER RESPECT
FASTER AYE VOTE THANK YOU KAY
THANK YOU.
AND WILL CALL THE ROLL THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN THIRTEEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA THE
MOTION IS TO PASSING REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE.
CENTER ABOUT ALL RIGHT WELL I
BATES.
BATES NOW DOLLY [inaudible]
DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI.
MCGUIRE MOREAU.
BROWN NO ROSS RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
STONE.
NO NO I'M BURKE CASKEY
[inaudible] FOURTEEN THIRTY YES
FIVE WHAT HAS HE AYE.
THEREFORE ROSA FAVOR THREE
OPPOSE WILL EITHER OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS -- AND YOU MAY GO
ON TO YOUR BILL.
WHICH IS AB.
FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING STATIONS THANK
YOU MISTER YOU HAVE THE 4%.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
CENTERS ON A START BY THINKING
THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL AND
I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENT ON PAGE FIVE
OF THE ANALYSIS.
IT'S TAKEN A DECADE TO BUILD OUT
THE NEARLY TWENTY THOUSAND
PUBLIC ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
STATIONS IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH A COMBINATION OF PRIVATE
INVESTMENT STATE DOLLARS AND
REPAIR FUNDS. TO REACH OUR
STATES GOAL OF THE POINT ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
WE WILL NEED TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND PUBLIC CHARGING
STATIONS.
EXISTING CHARGING STATIONS
PRIMARILY OFFER MOBILE PAYMENTS
SUCH AS TAP CARDS AND MOBILE
APPS TO INITIATE CHARGING
SESSIONS.
THIS IS CONSISTENT WITH CURRENT
LAW REQUIRING EVEY CHARGING
STATIONS TO ACCEPT PAYMENT VIA
CREDIT CARD OR MOBILE TECHNOLOGY
FOR BOTH.
HOWEVER THE EVER RESOURCES BOARD
IS PROPOSED REGULATION MANDATING
THAT ALL EXISTING AND FUTURE
PUBLIC CHARGING STATIONS BE
OUTFITTED WITH PHYSICAL CREDIT
CARD READERS.
WELL I APPRECIATE THE A
RESOURCES BOARD'S INTENTIONS
THIS REGULATION WOULD REQUIRE
EXISTING CHARGING STATIONS TO
UNDERGO COSTLY RETROFITS
REPLACEMENTS TO COMPLY.
REQUIRE CREDIT CARD READERS
WOULD ALSO ADD SIGNIFICANT COSTS
TO FUTURE INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND OPEN UP EVEY DRIVERS TO
SECURITY RISKS BY EMPLOYING LESS
SECURE TECHNOLOGY.
OUR LIMITED RESOURCES ARE BEST
SPENT A POINT INFRASTRUCTURE
EQUITABLY AND EFFICIENTLY TO
ENSURE THIS TECHNOLOGY REACHES
ALL COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA
SOME MORE SUPPORTING OUR STATE'S
AMBITIOUS CLIMBING GOALS.
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR PROPOSES
ON AN ALTERNATIVE THAT ENSURES
OPEN ACCESS TO CHARGING STATIONS
WITHOUT UNDERMINING THE PROGRESS
WE'VE MADE SO FAR.
I WOULD IT WOULD REQUIRE
CHARGING STATIONS TO BE EQUIPPED
WITH A TOLL FREE NUMBER FOR
CREDIT CARD PAYMENTS.
TAKEN OVER THE PHONE IN AT LEAST
TWO ADDITIONAL PAYMENT METHODS
INCLUDING A CREDIT CARD READER
OPTION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND WITH ME WITH ME TODAY
ARE CHRIS ROSE A RIVERS IN THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP.
AND MARGOT LOK CIARA FROM THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHRIS ROSE ON
BEHALF OF THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP IN SUPPORT OF
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR PROVIDES
ELECTRIC VEHICLE SERVICE
PROVIDERS THE FLEXIBILITY TO
RESPOND TO CUSTOMER CHOICE AND
PAYMENT TECHNOLOGY DEVELOPMENTS.
REQUIRING PHYSICAL CREDIT CARD
READERS WILL BE COSTLY AND THESE
ADDED COSTS WILL HAMPER EVEY
INFRASTRUCTURE DEPLOYMENT SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER LEVEL TWO
AND THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
PER DIRECT CURRENT FAST CHARGER
WITH OVER TEN THOUSAND CHARGERS
THAT WOULD BE NEEDED TO BE
RETROFITTED TO COMPLY WITH AT A
COST OF TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
MAINTENANCE COSTS FOR STATIONS
WITH PHYSICAL CREDIT CARD
READERS ARE SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
5210% WHICH CAN BE A
DISINCENTIVE TO SITE HOST TO
MAKE THEIR STATIONS PUBLIC.
REQUIRING PHYSICAL CREDIT CARD
READERS WILL UNDERMINE PUBLIC
INVESTMENTS FOR THE LAST TEN
YEARS THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION HAS INVESTED NEARLY A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
IN THE V. CHARGING STATIONS HALF
OF WHICH HAVE SUPPORTED PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE.
CHARGERS WHICH WOULD HAVE TO BE
REPLACED UNDER THESE REGULATIONS
THERE'S ALSO CONCERNED THAT
REQUIRING PHYSICAL CREDIT CARD
READERS HAMPER ACCESS TO THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
LAST YEAR'S REPORT PUBLISHED BY
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD TITLED
OVERCOMING BARRIERS TO CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION ACCESS FOR LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS.
IT STATES THAT MANY LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS LACK CREDIT CARDS AND
BANK ACCOUNTS.
GIVEN THE A ARBY'S OWN
RECOGNITION THAT CREDIT CARDS
ARE A BIGGER YEAR FOR LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS IT'S CLEAR THAT
CREDIT CARD READERS MANDATE
WOULD NOT EXPAND ACCESS TO LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES.
PLUS SMARTPHONES ARE MORE
PREVALENT THAN CREDIT CARDS
ACROSS ALL DEMOGRAPHICS.
GIVEN CALIFORNIA'S EVEY
DEPLOYMENT GOALS OF FIVE MILLION
EVEY IS BY TWENTY THIRTY AND A
QUARTER MILLION CHARGING POINTS
BY THE YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THE DESIRE TO
EXPAND EVEY ACCESS WE BELIEVE BY
GIVING INDUSTRY THE FLEXIBILITY
TO RESPOND TO CUSTOMER CHOICE
AND A DEVELOPMENT IN TECHNOLOGY
WILL SERVE.
THESE GOALS BETTER RATHER THAN
MANDATING A LITTLE USED AND SOON
TO BE OUTDATED PAYMENT METHOD.
CALIFORNIA LEADS THE NATION IN
CLIMATE ACTION AS WELL AS
DEVELOPING TECHNOLOGY PLEASE LET
US CONTINUE TO LEAD THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON YOU'RE GOING.
TO GOOD AFTERNOON MR TURNED
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAKE A LECTURE
ON BEHALF OF THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING ASSOCIATION.
AS X. AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
RUFFORD WE'RE CONCERNED WITH HOW
THIS REGULATION ROOM PACKED THE
THE THE THE CURRENT AND FUTURE
STATE.
OF CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE IN
THE STATE AND IMPACT OF CLIMATE
GOALS AND OUR ADOPTION OF FIVE
MILLION YOU FEES.
FIRST OFF THE NEARLY TWENTY
THOUSAND CHARGING STARTERS
INSTALLED IN CALIFORNIA TO DATE
TO COULD DECADES TO BUILD OUT
STARTING FROM SCRATCH AND IT
TOOK A COMBINATION OF PRIVATE
INVESTMENT STATE DOLLARS AND
REPAIR FUNDS.
THE REGULATION AS PROPOSED
THREATENS TO WIPE OUT A SIZEABLE
PORTION OF THIS INVESTMENT.
WE DO NOT THINK THIS IS AN
EFFICIENT USE OF LIMITED PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE INVESTMENT DOLLARS.
FURTHERMORE THE FUTURE OF PUBLIC
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE IS ALSO
ADVERSELY IMPACTED BY THIS
REGULATION.
THE ADDED COSTS WILL.
CAN WILL SEVERELY IMPACT HOW
MUCH MORE INFRASTRUCTURE CAN BE
DEPLOYED BY A ARBY'S OWN
ESTIMATE IT RANGES FROM A
HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION TO FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. FOR
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS YOU
CAN GET SIXTY SEVEN THOUSAND
MORE CHARGING STATIONS OUT THERE.
WHAT IT ALSO DOES IS IT
INCREASES THE COST OF THE --
CHARGING STE CHARGING STATION TO
AN EXTENT FOR IT MIGHT BECOME
UNAFFORDABLE FOR A SITE HOSTED A
CUSTOMER TO EVEN AFFORD A
RUNNING AN OPERATING A CHARGING
STATION -- AND AND THIS WILL
LEAD TO TO CONSEQUENCES ONE OF
WHICH A CHART OF A SITE OR
NUMBER TO INCREASE THE PRICE OF
OF THE CHARGING.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF THE
PERCENTAGE OF THE CHARGING
STATION THIS WILL
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT LOW
INCOME POPULATIONS.
AND COULD LEAD DOWN TO SHUT
DOWNS AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THE REASON BEING
THAT CHARGING STATIONS ARE USE
LAST AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
AND THESE ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
LIKELY TO BE IMPACTED THE MOST.
THERE ARE BETTER WAYS TO DO
BUSINESS THERE ARE BETTER WAYS
TO YOU KNOW -- PUT CHARGING
STATIONS OUT THERE AND THAT IS
WHY WE'VE BEEN OF OPEN TO MOST
OF THE SUGGESTIONS IN THE BILL
ALL OF THEM.
INCLUDING CONTACTLESS CARDS AND
IT.
AS WE SEE IT AS WE SEE PAYMENT
TECHNOLOGIES INCREASINGLY MOVING
AWAY FROM EMV CHIP READERS THE
DIGITAL AND CONTEST LESS FORMS
OF PAYMENT.
ALSO -- SINCE CARD READERS ARE
EXTERNAL. TO TO THE CHARGING
STATIONS WEATHER ELEMENTS CAN
LEAD TO FREQUENT MALFUNCTIONS
AND CAN CAN YOU TO HIRE MONTH
FUNCTION COSTS.
AND ART THIS COULD BE TO THE
DETRIMENT OF CONSUMERS IN EUROPE --
WHERE MOST OF THE CHARGING
STATIONS DO NOT ENOUGH INCLUDE
CHART -- IN BE READERS ARE
DISPLAYS THE RELIABILITY RATE IS
NINETY NINE POINT 7% WE'RE NOT
GONNA SEE THAT HERE IF WE
INSTALL THESE CREDIT CARD
READERS.
AS AN INDUSTRY WE SHARE THE
ARBY'S GOAL FOR UNIVERSAL
CONVENIENT AT NECK QUITABLE
ACCESS TO CHARGING STATIONS WE
FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT MULTIPLE
PAYMENT MECHANISMS PROPOSED
MAYBE.
FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR ARE
CONSISTENT WITH CONSUMER PAYMENT
TRENDS WITH GLOBAL BEST
PRACTICES AND MORE TECHNOLOGY IN
REGULATION. FOR THESE REASONS WE
ARE DRY VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS SPEAKERS --
JUST STATE YOUR NAME AND OCT YOU
KNOW GROUP THE REPRESENT THEIR
AT KROGER'S WITH ET CONNECT WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL AND
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN FOR IS.
MUCH NEEDED LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE.
AS CHAIR MARK PRIOR HERE ON
BEHALF OF CHARGE POINT WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE MEASURE AND ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF THE PRIOR SPEAKERS
WE ARE TRYING YOU.
STRUCTURE MEMBERS MIKE MONEY
GOING TO BE AT THE COALITION
CALIFORNIA UTILITY EMPLOYEES IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
OKAY.
MR CHER CAM DIMITRI WITH TECHNO
AND STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL.
OKAY -- OKAY -- LET'S HEAR FROM
ANY OPPOSE OPPOSE. TO THIS BILL
[inaudible]
WERE ON AB. ONE FOUR TWO FOUR
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M CATHERINE
GARCIA WITH ON BEHALF OF THE
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA.
THE CALIFORNIA OPPOSES ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR WHICH
WOULD UNDERMINE THE CALIFORNIA
RESOURCES EVERY SOURCES BOARDS
OF FORTY TO ENSURE MORE RELIABLE
AND EQUITABLE CHARGER ACCESS.
FOR ALL EVEY DRIVERS THIS BILL
SHOULD BE HELD SINCE CARBS
REGULATORY PROCESS IS CURRENTLY
UNDER WAY -- BASED ON THE EEVEE
CHARGING STATIONS OPEN ACCESS
BACK FROM.
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN THE RULE
WILL GO TO VOTE IN TWO DAYS.
CALIFORNIANS ONE A STATE IN
WHICH ALL RESIDENTS CAN PURCHASE
CAN ANTICIPATE CLEAN AIR DAYS.
AND WHERE WE CAN REDUCE CRIME IT
POLLUTIONFROM INTERNAL
COMBUSTION ENGINES WE HAVE SAID
A CRITICAL GOAL OF REACHING FIVE
MILLION ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
ON OUR ROADS BY.
TWENTY THIRTY THIS REQUIRES THAT
WE MAKE IT AS ACCESSIBLE AND
CONVENIENT AS POSSIBLE TO USE
EVEY CHARGING STATIONS.
AB DRIVERS SHOULD BE ABLE TO
CHARGE THEIR CAR AT CHARGING
STATIONS WITH A CREDIT CARD JUST
AS THEY WOULD EXPECT TO RE FUEL
AT GAS STATIONS.
AND GAS STATIONS ARE NOT SAYING
THAT CREDIT CARD READERS ARE NOT
GOING TO BE AROUND IN A FEW
YEARS YOU KNOW THIS IS WHAT
WE'RE USING TODAY AND IT WILL BE
GOING ON FOR MANY YEARS TO COME.
GIVEN THAT RANGING VARIETY IS A
REAL CONCERN THE CHARGING
EXPERIENCE SHOULD NOT BE
INTIMIDATING IF THE CHARTER
DOESN'T HAVE A CREDIT CARD
READER.
USERS MUST EITHER OBTAIN A
MEMBERSHIP CARD IN ADVANCE OR
DOWN THE CHARGING COMPANIES
MOBILE APP IN THIS HAS THREE
REQUIREMENTS.
THAT MEANS THE USER MUST HAVE A
SMARTPHONE SUFFICIENT CELL PHONE
COVERAGE AND AMPLE DATA.
WE SHOULD STRIVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE ELIMINATING ANY
BARRIERS TO EXPAND EVEY ADOPTION
TO A BROADER BASE OF DRIVERS.
DEVELOPING RELIABLE AND EASY TO
USE CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE IS
FUNDAMENTAL TO ACCELERATING THE
TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES AND CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY AND
OTHERS SPEAKERS PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MR CARE MEMBERS MY NAME IS ROCKY
RUSSIAN REPRESENTING COALITION
CLEAN AIR.
UNFORTUNATELY CALLS FOR CLEAN
AIR MUST POSE A. B..
FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR CALIFORNIA
FACES A PRESSING NEED TO
ACCELERATE THE TRANSITION FROM
INTERNAL COMBUSTION ENGINE TWO
ZERO NATION TRANSITION --
TRANSPORTATION WE MUST UP A BAR
EMISSION REDUCTION EFFORTS AND
THAT MEANS MAKING ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES ACCESSIBLE TO THE
GREATEST NUMBER OF DRIVERS.
SB TWELVE SEVENTY FIVE OF TWENTY
FOURTEEN ENVISIONED A MARKET FOR
EVEY IS NOT JUST FOR THE TECH
SAVVY NOT JUST FOR THE WELL
HEELED.
BUT FOR LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS AND THOSE WHO LIVE IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THE
STAGE FOR SB TWELVE SEVENTY FIVE
WAS SET IN.
TWENTY THIRTEEN WITH THE PASSAGE
OF SB FOUR FIFTY FOUR WHICH
MISTER CHAIRMAN I BELIEVE YOU
ORDERED FOR AS DID SENATOR
GALGIANI.
SB FOR FOOD FOR PROVIDED THE
FRAMEWORK SO EVEY CHARGING
STATIONS COULD OPERATE LIKE GAS
STATIONS TO BEST ASSIST THE
STATE IN REACHING ITS THEY HAVE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION.
AND AIR POLLUTION REDUCTION
GOALS.
DRIVERS CAN FILL UP THE GAS
STATIONS WITH THE CHARGE CARD
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO SO AT
CHARGING STATIONS.
WE'RE STRIVING FOR TRANSITION TO
MISSION FREE VEHICLES THAT IS IS
IS IS SEAMLESS AS POSSIBLE
LIMITING PAYMENT METHODS. TO PAY
UP PRIOR -- TO RFID TAGS A ONE
EIGHT HUNDRED NUMBER OR OTHER
CONTACTLESS METHODS IS CERTAINLY
NOT THE WAY TO GET THERE. TO
ACHIEVE THESE GOALS ARE ARE --
EVEY ADOPTION GOALS -- PUBLIC
CHARGING CAN BE NEITHER
INCONVENIENT OR CONFUSING AND
JUST -- NOTE ON WHETHER OR NOT.
CHARGE CARDS ARE A METHOD OF THE
PAST ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN
BANKING ASSOCIATION.
BY THE END OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THERE ARE THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
FOUR MILLION OPEN CREDIT CARD
ACCOUNTS -- STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
THAT AT LEAST. SEVEN IN TEN
AMERICANS HAVE AT LEAST ONE
CREDIT CARD IN THEIR WALLETS SO
DID THE DEATH KNELL THE TO BEING
RUN BY SOME FOR CREDIT CARDS I
THINK IS.
A LITTLE BIT PREMATURE RIGHT NOW
THANK YOU.
OTHER SPEAKERS OF IN FAVOR --
DOUBTFIRE YOUR ORGANIZATION IN
YOUR POSITION.
ONLY PLEASE THANK YOU.
THIS IS THE OPPOSITION.
WHAT IS THE OPPOSITION YEAH?
OPPOSITION PLEASE OPPOSITION
START.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- TEAR BILL BILL --
BY SIR BATES AND THERE WAS A
COMMITTEE MINIMUS AIR CARLIN
ARABS AND GREEN LOTS -- GROUND
IS A LEADING PROVIDER OF EASY
CHARGING SOFTER AND SERVICES AND
EVEN ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN
GROWING MARKET FOR
TRANSPORTATION EDUCATION.
ACROSS CALIFORNIA -- I'M HERE
TODAY TO COMMUNICATE GREEN LOTS
DISAPPOINTMENT WITH AND A STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE PRESENT
VERSION OF A. B.. FOURTEEN
TWENTY FOUR GREEN NOT TESTIFIED
IT BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE SIX
YEARS AGO IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
FIVE FOR WHICH THE INSTANT.
LEGISLATION WOULD A REPLACE --
WILL SLOW TO DEVELOP THE A
RESOURCE BOARD LEAD REGULATORY
PROCESS IS NEARING FINALIZATION
WE DO NOT SUPPORT CURTAILING.
OR OTHERWISE SUPERSEDING THAT
PROCESS THE LEGISLATION.
WELL -- THE REGULATION MAYBE IN
PERFECT IT IS RAPIDLY EVOLVING
AND WE BELIEVE THE REGULATORY
PROCESS PROVIDES GROUP BUS AN
APPROPRIATE VENUE -- FOR ALL
PARTIES -- TO STATED HE SENT A
BALANCED DIVERSE POLICY AND
MARKET PERSPECTIVES.
THE MAIN OBJECTIVE SP FOUR FIVE
FOUR WAS CREATED OPEN AND ACTUAL
ACCESS TO CHARGE HIM A STRUCTURE
FOR CALIFORNIANS.
THIS WITH THESE BARRIERS TO
ADOPTION ELECTRIC VEHICLES WILL
ESTABLISH A MORE SUSTAINABLE
MARKET AND INDUSTRY.
AB FOURTEENTH.
THE FOURTH STANDS TO UNDERMINE
DECAL AT PUTTING PUTTING CERTAIN
CORPORATE INTERESTS IN FRONT OF
THE CHARGING PUBLIC.
CRITICALLY THE BILL CONSERVE
FUSES FLEXIBILITY AN OPTION AUDI
FOR CREATING CHARGING -- FOR FOR
A FOR CONSUMERS ACCESS CHARTING
A STRUCTURE WITH CORPORATE
FLEXIBILITY IN HOW TO PROVIDE
THAT ACCESS -- WELL THIS BILL
HAS PUT THE INDUSTRY.
IT SHOULD BE ILLUSTRATIVE THAT
ALL THE CONSUMER GROUPS
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS AND
INFORMAL JUSTICE GROUPS THAT
HAVE WEIGHED IN OPPOSE THIS BILL.
IN CONCLUSION GREEN LAST DOES
NOT BELIEVE IT IS APPROPRIATE TO
SUPERSEDE AS BEFORE BUT FOR AND
CAR DEALERS THE REGULATORY
PROCESS AND AS SUCH GREEN MONTHS
OR DOES YOUR NOTEBOOK VOTE.
OR AT LEAST A FOR ACTION UNTIL
AFTER CARP ACTS ON THURSDAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MILES MILLAR SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL HERE IN OPPOSITION TO A.
B. -- FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR WOULD
UNDERMINE RELIABLE ACCESSBY
PROHIBITING ANY STATE AGENCY
FROM REQUIRING CHARGING STATIONS
ACCEPT CREDIT CARD PAYMENT.
IN THE FORM THE MOST ALIGNED
WITH CUSTOMER EXPECTATION IN
UNIVERSAL ACCESS.
BECAUSE WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO PAY
FOR CHARGING AT THE STATIONS
JUST AS THEY WOULD EXPECT TO BE
ABLE.
TO A GAS STATIONS ARE PARKING
METERS.
NOT RESIGNED CONTACTLESS CARDS
OR PROPRIETARY FOBS.
WHICH MANY CUSTOMERS MAY LACK.
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR WOULD
ALSO UNDERMINE AN ONGOING PUBLIC
REGULATORY PROCESS UNDER WAY AT
A ARE BEING.
UNDER THE AUTHORITY GRANTED TO
IT BY SB.
FOUR FIFTY FOUR WHAT WE
UNDERSTAND THE EAGERNESS TO MOVE
TO THE PAYMENT FORMS OF THE
FUTURE.
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT THE
CHARGING STATIONS APPOINT TODAY
ARE LINED WITH THE PAYMENT FORMS
OF THE PRESIDENT.
AND THE CALIFORNIA DOES NOT
LEAVE ANY DRIVERS BEHIND IN
PREMATURELY RACING TOWARDS THE
FUTURE.
ACCORDINGLY WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO HOLD THIS BILL
FOR NOW UNTIL SUCH TIME AS A OR
B. AS FINISH THE ONGOING
REGULATORY PROCESS THANK YOU.
JUST SECOND -- OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY ONE WHICH YES GO HEAD
START AND MISTER CHAIRMAN
CAPULETS REPRESENTING PLUG IN
AMERICA WE WERE THE ORIGINAL
SPONSOR OF SENATOR CORBETT'S
BILL.
WERE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL AND
WE'D LIKE THE OTHER WITNESSES
URGE THAT WE WAIT UNTIL AFTER
THE A. R. B. PROCESS COMPLETES
ITS WORK ON THURSDAY IT'S BEEN
AN EIGHTEEN MONTH PROCESS THANK
YOU -- OKAY -- QUESTION MARK
COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND WHILE I I VERY MUCH
RESPECT THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
SPOKEN OPPOSITION OF MY BILL I
THINK THEIR OPPOSITION TO LITTLE
MISPLACED A COUPLE OF POINTS
THAT WERE MADE.
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR DOES NOT
GUT SB FOUR FIFTY FOUR THE
OPTIONS LAID OUT MAYBE FOURTEEN
TWENTY FOUR ARE STRONGER.
IN TERMS OF ACCESSIBILITY IN
CONSUMER CHOICE THE EXISTING LAW
UNDER AS BEFORE FIFTY FOUR I'M
GOING TO DETAILS OF ANYONE HAS
QUESTIONS -- THE ISSUE OF CREDIT
CARDS VERSES MOBILE PHONES WAS
BROUGHT WAS BROUGHT UP.
A WE WANNA MAKE ELECTRIC
VEHICLES ACCESSIBLE TO FOLKS IN
ALL COMMUNITIES ACROSS ALL
INCOME LEVELS THAT PAYMENT
STANDARDS UNDER A. B. FOURTEEN
TWENTY FOUR DO NOT REQUIRE
DRIVERS TO HAVE A SMART PHONE.
TWO USING THE V. CHARGING
STATION BUT IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
TO UNDERSTAND THAT SMARTPHONE
OWNERSHIP IS MORE YOU BAKER THIS
IN LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES IN
CREDIT CARD OWNERSHIP IS 67% OF
ADULTS EARNING LESS THAN THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
ON A SMART UP ON A SMARTPHONE
THE CORNER PEW RESEARCH CENTER
AND ONLY 60%.
OF HOUSEHOLDS EARNING LESS THAN
FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR ON
A CREDIT CARD.
ACCORDING TO FEDERAL RESERVE
DATA FROM.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND THE
ISSUE OF CELL RECEPTION WAS ALSO
BROUGHT UP REQUIRING CREDIT CARD
READERS WOULD NOT SOLVE THE
ISSUE OF A CELL PHONE NOT HAVING
RECEPTION WHICH CREDIT CARD
READERS ALSO NEED CELL PHONE
RECEPTION. TO WORK IN A PROCESS
PAYMENTS -- RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE.
OKAY -- WE HAVE MOTION LET'S
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS SENATOR ABOUT BY.
WELL I BATES HI BATES AYE DALI.
DALI AYE DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI MCGUIRE MORALE
MORRELL AYE ROSS RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER STONE.
STONE I AM BURKE.
I'M BURKE I WOULD CASSIE.
OKAY WILL BE ABLE TO FAVOR
LIBERAL FASTENER WE HAVE ONE
MORE BILL -- ASSEMBLYMAN
ASSEMBLY WOMAN OF OUR CARE --
LET'S OPEN THE ROLE -- FOR AS A
SENATOR -- DOLLY SO.
HE CAN VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CALL THE ROLL PLEASE ON
THE FIRST CONSENT.
ON THE FIRST CONSENT CALENDAR
WHICH CONSISTS OF FILE ITEMS
257-913-1617 EIGHTEEN AND
NINETEEN SENATOR DOLLINGER.
ALI AYE GALGIANI MCGUIRE MORALE.
MORRELL AYE ROTH SKINNER AMBERG.
OKAY WERE ON THAT A CONSENT
COUNTER WE HAVE.
EIGHT ZERO AND LEAVE THE ROLE
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS NOW
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THE SECOND ONE TOO AND HE HAS
ONE OF THE BILL.
YOU WANNA ADD ON TO SECOND ROLE
OKAY WILL CALL THE ROLL ON THE
SECOND CONSENT ORDER ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH CONSISTS
OF FILE ITEMS WENT INTO THIS IS
THE SECOND CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATOR DALI.
DALI AYE MCGUIRE MORALE MORRELL
AYE ROSS SKINNER NUMBER. ZERO
NINE ZERO HE ALSO [inaudible]
FOURTEEN THIRTY CALDERON -- AB
FOURTEEN THIRTEEN THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN THIRTEEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE.
CENTER DOLLY [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
ROUGH [inaudible]
SKINNER NUMBER.
THANK YOU FOR THREE FOUR THREE
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS AND GO TO THE A. B. THE
NEXT ITEM.
THIS IS AB.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE LAST BILL
TODAY'S ONLY ONE YOU HAVE THE
FLOOR.
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
SAM LOSING THE ONLY PERSON THE
COMMITTEES ALREADY VOTED -- FOR
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT AB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE THAT WILL
ALLOW REGIONAL TRANSIT AGENCIES
TO UTILIZE THE CONSTRUCTION
MANAGER GENERAL CONTRACTORS CMG
C. PROCUREMENT PROCESS FOR OFF
HIGHWAY CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS.
THE SEA AND YOU SEE DELIVERY
METHOD ALLOWS THE GENERAL
CONTRACTOR TO ENGAGE THE
CONSTRUCTION MANAGER EARLY TO
WRITE INPUT DURING THE DESIGN
PROCESS THIS ALLOWS THEM TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY TO DEVELOP THE
PROJECT SCOPE AN OPTIMIZED
DESIGN IMPROVE QUALITY AND
MANAGE COST.
CALTRANS IS USE THIS PROCESS TO
SAVE OVER FORTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE CYCLE WHICH WAS
20% OF THEIR COSTS.
BY USING THIS PROCESS.
EXISTING LAW DOES NOT ALLOW
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES
TO UTILIZE THE CNBC AND IS
REQUIRED A PATCHWORK OF BILLS BY
THE LEGISLATURE TO ALLOW US TO
USE THESE METHODS ON DIFFERENT
PROJECTS.
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE GIVES
THE REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES ANOTHER TOOL AND
THEY'RE ABOUT TO DELIVER
PROJECTS MORE EFFICIENTLY AND
PROVIDE OPTIONS FOR SMALLER
MUNICIPALITIES. TO UTILIZE THIS
PROCUREMENT PROCESS TO SAVE
MONEY AND BE MORE EFFICIENT WITH
ME TODAY'S MARC WATTS
REPRESENTING THE CONTRA COSTA
TRANSIT AUTHORITY.
THE STORE.
MICHELLE REMEMBERS MARC WATTS --
WE'RE PLEASED TO HAVE -- THE
MEMBER SPONSOR OF THIS
LEGISLATION FOR US -- WE'RE
INTENDING TO USE INITIALLY --
THE AUTHORITY IN THIS BILL TO
HELP. ONE OF OUR AGENCY ENTITY
MEMBERS OF OUR AGENCY.
TO CONSTRUCT A BRIDGE JOHN IN
SAN RAMON SO WITH THAT WEEKS.
HAS FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND YOUR
AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK.
AFTER CENTER BELL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO A FULL BORE I CAN
WITH A CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION WE APPRECIATE.
DE -- THE CHAIR FOR HEARING
DISPOSABLES THE COMEDIAN WORKING
ON THIS -- IN OUR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE THE COMMISSIO CALLS
FOR ADDITIONAL TOOL FOR REGIONAL
LOCAL PARTNERS TO BE ABLE.
TO DELIVER PROJECTS MORE
EFFICIENTLY AND BE ALSO ABLE TO
MITIGATE ANY COSTS.
INCLUDING IN SB ONE OR
EXPECTATIONS BUT THE LEGISLATURE
FOR INCREASE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
EFFICIENCY IN MANAGING PUBLIC
INVESTMENT IN TRANSPORTATION.
EXPANDING THE USE OF THE C. M.
G. C. APPROACH HAS BEEN PROVEN
BY BOTH CALTRANS AND THE FEDERAL
HIGHWAY ADMINISTRATION.
AND THIS METHOD COULD SAY
PROJECT DELIVER TIME IMPROVE
DESIGN QUALITY AND COST CONTROL
OPTIMIZED CONSTRUCTION SCHEDULES
AND MITIGATING RISKS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
BOTH AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTION WE HAVE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU.
TURNS ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
COUNCIL OF ENGINEERING COMPANIES
WE HAVE A SUPPORT COMMENDED ON
THIS BILL -- ARE ONE HOLD UP IS
THE DEFINITION THE BILL
CONSTRUCTION MANAGER.
WHICH IS INNOCUOUS BY ITSELF
TODAY BUT WE THINK IS A
NECESSARY IN PAIRS WITH THE RISK
OF POTENTIAL IN THE FUTURE.
FOR A BEING MISAPPLIED MISUSED --
OUTSIDE OF THIS SEEMS YOU SEE
CONTEXT AND SERVE FOR THOSE
REASONS WITH SPORTSMAN ON THE
BILL.
AGAIN NO ISSUE WITH THE BILL
ITSELF APPRECIATE WORKING WITH
THE OFFERING HER STAFF AND AGREE
WITH HER EFFORT TO PROVIDE LOCAL
AGENCIES WITH ADDITIONAL
CONTRACTING FLEXIBILITY THANK
YOU.
THEY SUPPORTERS PLEASE.
AUDREY RETIRED CHECK FROM CRUISE
STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNCILS OF GOVERNMENT AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS KATONA HIT
AROUND THE CITY COUNCIL LABORS
IN STRONG SUPPORT ON THIS BILL
ENSURES THAT FIRMS PROVIDE
APPROPRIATELY LICENSE
ENGINEERING AND CONTRACTING
SERVICES THE OKAY ARE OPPOSITION
ANY OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
SEE.
NINE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
COMMENT SIR BATES YES FIVE JUST
A SHORT COMMENT ABOUT WITH THE
GENTLEMAN FROM ECC ARE SAD I SAW
THE LETTER AND HAVE TO AGREE
THAT WHILE THE DEFINITION CHANGE
FOR CONSTRUCTION MANAGER IS FINE.
A WHILE LIMITED TO THE CONTACTS
ARE OF THIS BILL IT WOULD BE ARE
PROBLEMATIC IF AFTER THE BILL IS
CHAPTER.
I IT WAS APPLIED BEYOND JUST THE
CM G. C. ON SINCE THAT WOULD BE
ARTIFICIALLY LIMITING -- POOL
THAT OUR LOCAL AGENCIES CAN
CHOOSE FROM TO SERVE AS A
CONSTRUCTION MANAGER ON PROJECTS
SO THAT BEING SAID I'M
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL BUT I
THINK IT'S HALF OF CAUTION.
THAT SHOULD BE ON THE RECORD
GOING FORWARD.
WITHOUT JUST I SEE YOU'RE MAKING
A NOTE SO ABOUT FIVE THANK YOU
FOR THAT.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES THANK
YOU MADAM VICE CHAIR
[inaudible]
AND SER DOT.
YEAH MOTIONS AND ASSEMBLY SEVEN
ONE YOU CAN CLOSE.
THE BILL HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT THUS FAR AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IPHONE.
OKAY CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BARKING
HAND THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
CENTER BOUNCE HI WELL I BATES HI
BATES AYE DOLLY DOT.
DOT DOT I'D TELL JOHNNY.
WEIR MORALE.
WELL I'VE ROTH RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER STONE.
STONE I AM BURKE CASKEY.
OKAY SIX EARLY THE ROBE FLAPS
AND MEMBERS.
THANK YOU AND WE'LL TRY TO GET
AS MANY OF THEM HERE AS WE CAN.
RIGHT NOW.
THOSE WHO HAVEN'T VOTED YET.
SENATOR BATES WOULD LIKE. TO
TWENTY FOURTEEN A SIX CALL THE
ROLL ONS -- COULD HAVE THE ROLL
CALL AND WELL ROLL.
FORTINO.
SIX ASSEMBLY BILL FORTINO SIX
PRICE IN THE MEMBER OF DONALD
PROMOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
CENTER BATES AYE BATES AYE
MORALE.
MORRELL AYE ROTH.
HE WANTS TO KNOW IF YOU MISTER
THOUGH WITH THE AGENDA.
THAT WAS THE LAST ONE YEAH
[inaudible] ONE HI I AM.
TWENTY CONSENT CALENDAR IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
YEAH I MEAN THIS.
SO WE'RE GOOD.
THANK YOU SIR [inaudible]
LOOKS LIKE.
WHAT A WAY TO HELP HIM FIND?
LET'S SEE [inaudible]
ONE THREE THE SERVER
[inaudible] SIX PLEASE.
THIS IS THE SENATE BILL FIVE
SIXTEEN BISON REMEMBER TO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY.
CENTER BATES.
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE MORALE.
MORRELL NO ROTH [inaudible]
SKINNER.
I'M BURKE FOR CASSIE.
WELL SIX VOTES. TO NOT TO NOT.
LEAVE THEIR OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS AND GO TO HIS NEXT.
OKAY WE'VE GOT ONE MORE.
FOR LIKE.
IT'S FINISHED OKAY [inaudible]
THANKS
[inaudible]
RED.
OKAY WE HAVE -- SENATORS ON THE
WAY WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AS SOON AS WE HAVE. ONE MORE
SENATOR [inaudible]
SEN RUBIO.
JUST JUST
[inaudible]
FOR YES [inaudible]
YEAH -- JUST [inaudible] TO THE
YEAH.
HOW DOES MY MY [inaudible]
CRAZINESS [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY -- WILL OPEN THE ROLE IN
THE BILL SO WE HAVE. THREE
CENTERS WILL CALL THE ROLL.
SO LET'S OPEN WITH THE FIRST
ITEMS.
ON THE FIRST CONSENT CALENDAR
WHICH CONSISTS OF FILE ITEMS
257-913-1617 EIGHTEEN AND
NINETEEN CENTER GALGIANI.
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE ROSS.
BRASS I SKINNER NUMBER
[inaudible]
NUMBER I ELEVEN VOTES ON THE
CONSENT COUNTER.
ONE ON THE SECOND CONSENT
CALENDAR WHICH CONSISTS OF FILE
ITEMS ONE AND TWENTY CENTER
MCGUIRE.
I ROTH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER NUMBER
[inaudible]
NUMBER HI [inaudible] TWELVE
ZERO I BELIEVE THE ROLE FRESNO
NUMBERS.
THIS IS A SIMPLY BILL FORTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAILY
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND WE'RE FOR TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CENTER RAS.
ROTH AYE SKINNER.
I'M BURKE.
HI NUMBER I WOULD HOUSE HE HAS
ELEVEN VOTES IN FAVOR.
LEAVE THE ROAD OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE SEVENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMOS THE MOTION
IS DO PASS AND REFER TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
SENATE ROTH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER.
NUMBER COMPLY NUMBER AYE. TWELVE
TO ZERO THE BILL WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THIS IS A ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
SIXTEEN BY SIMILAR TO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY.
SENATOR BATES.
ROSS ROTH AYE SKINNER
[inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
KATHY. SEVEN VOTES IN FAVOR
LEAVE THE ROAD OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL FORTINO
SIX FIRES IN A MEMBER O'DONNELL
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
CENTER ROTH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER STONE.
I'M BURKE NUMBER I WILL COUNTY.
TEN ZERO THOSE TEN VOTES IN
FAVOR.
LEAVE THE ROLE FROM FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN THIRTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GLORIA THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE.
SENATOR DOLLINGER GALGIANI
MCGUIRE.
ROSS ROSS I SKINNER [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
RIGHT. FIVE VOTES IN FAVOR LEAVE
THE ROLE FROM FRANCE AND MEMBERS
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
TWENTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY UTILITIES
AND COMMUNICATIONS.
SENATOR GALGIANI MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE ROSS ROTH AYE
SKINNER [inaudible]
WHAT COUNTY?
YEAH.
THAT'S TEN LOS IN FAVOR LEAVE
THE ROLE FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN BY PHONE THE MEMORANDA SO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE.
CENTER DOLLY MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
MORALE ROSS ROSS I SKINNER.
I'M BURKE.
NUMBER AYE.
TURN THOSE IN FAVOR REALLY THE
ROLE WILL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
THIS IS A TIME THE BILL FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
POWER COME HAND MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFER TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE SENATOR
DOLLINGER.
GALGIANI MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
ROSS ROSS I SKINNER I'M BURKE.
NUMBER I WILL COUNTY. NINE NINE
VOTES IN FAVOR LEAVE THE ROLE
FROM FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
DOES.
REQUIRE.
X.
[inaudible]
CAPITAL.
OUR WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON ON FOR
CENTER GALGIANI. FOR THE ROLE
PLEASE.
NO JUST WHEN SHE TO VOTE.
FOR ON THE FIRST CONSENT
CALENDAR WHICH CONSISTS OF FILE
ITEMS 257-913-1617 EIGHTEEN AND
NINETEEN CENTER GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE [inaudible] TWELVE
THERE. TWELVE ZERO LEAVE THE
ROPE IN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
WAITING FOR CENTERS COUNTER
SHE'S IN THE SCHERING PUBLIC
SAFETY. FOURTEEN THIRTEEN IS THE
NEXT.
COURT.
THIS IS A SIMILAR BILL FOURTEEN
THIRTEEN BY SIMILAR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GLORIA THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE.
CENTER DOLLY GALGIANI GALGIANI
AYE.
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
SKINNER NUMBER.
THE SIX SUPPOSED TO FAVOR LEE
THE ROLE FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THIS IS A SIMPLY BILL FOURTEEN
TWENTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENED AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY UTILITIES
AND COMMUNICATIONS.
SENATOR GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
SKINNER WHAT CASKEY. ELEVEN ZERO
SEVEN ZERO LEAD ROLE FROM.
THIS IS A SYMBOL FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAUER CAM THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
SENATOR DOLLINGER GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE SKINNER.
WE CASKEY.
YOU FUND TENS -- STERN VOTES IN
FAVOR LEAVES ARE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS
SKINNER HAD DOUBLE DUTY
TODAY DURING HER COMMITTEE SO.
THE SERVER BY A NOSE.
SHE HAD TO DO DOUBLE DUTY
.
IS IN THE
OKAY -- FOR THE FINAL
TIME WE WILL LIFT THE CALLS ON
ON ALL THE BILLS WILL CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE.
ON GO THROUGH THE ROLE ON THE
FIRST CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH
CONSISTS OF FILE ITEMS
257-913-1617 EIGHTEEN AND
NINETEEN CENTER SKINNER
[inaudible]
SKINNER AYE [inaudible]
YEAH. THIRTEEN ZERO GRAYSON ON
THE SECOND CONSENT CALENDAR
WHICH CONSISTS OF FILE ITEMS ONE
AND TWO CENTER SKINNER.
WAITING TO WITHOUT. SEVEN ONE
WAIT A MINUTE HOLD ON NO CONSENT
CALENDAR TO NOTE CONSENT.
I AM.
THE TWENTY YES.
THAT THE DOCUMENT CENTER WANTED.
TO THE LIMIT. ONE IN. TWENTY
NINE STATES SO YOU NEVER.
HAD BONE CANCER THAT'S RIGHT
OKAY THAT HAS TWELVE VOTES IN
FAVOR.
THAT HOUSES THAT PASSES. TO HIM
THE EXCITEMENT.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAILY
THE MOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
CENTER SKINNER [inaudible]
HI. TWELVE TO ZERO IN MOTION
THAT THE HOUSE [inaudible]
PASSES YES.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
SEVENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RAST THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
YOUR FOR TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
CENTER SKINNER. ONE SEVEN NINE
SEVEN ZERO EIGHT AS CENTER
SKINNER.
SKINNER I AND WHAT COUNTY
BECAUSE HE AYE.
THAT IS NINE VOTES IN FAVOR OF
THE MOTION PASSES.
THIS IS A FAMILY BILL FORTINO
SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
CENTER SKINNER. FIVE SKINNER I
WILL COUNTY.
NO CASTING NOW. ELEVEN VOTES IN
FAVOR ONE OPPOSE THE MOTION
CARRIES.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN THIRTEEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE CENTER SKINNER
[inaudible]
SKINNER HI.
THOSE SEVEN VOTES IN FAVOR OF
THE MOTION PASSES THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND WE'RE FOR TO THE COMMITTEE
ON ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS.
CENTER SKINNER.
HI SKINNER AYE WIECKOWSKI WE
HAVE THE AYE. THIRTEEN THAT IS
THIRTEEN VOTES IN FAVOR THAT
PASSES.
THIS IS A SEND A BILL FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
**** THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE.
CENTER SKINNER.
IN OUR AYE.
TENNIS LEVELS IN FAVORITE PASSES
EXIST IN THE BILL FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
POWER QUE HAN THE MISSION IS TO
PASS AND REFER TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CENTER SKINNER SKINNER I WILL
COUNTY BECAUSE HE AYE. TWELVE
ZERO THAT MOTION CARRIES.
THANK YOU EVERYBODY.
THE VIDEO THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION BASINGER